e
everybody and good morning to our public
um I'm going to first announce how Rick
lad uh addresses and discusses some of
the issues in executive session I'm
going to open up a couple of these bills
and not take any motions we're going to
have some discussion first we've done
that many times in education policy
where we have concerns where we can draw
upon technical support if we need it and
then I will then announce when I'm ready
to take motions and I will address
somebody to make a motion after we have
this discussion first we break into
caucuses where we meet as a caucus
either side and try to determine okay
with this new information we gathered
where is your team going to be and
they'll come back and I'll take a motion
and we'll move on with it and so
starting out in today's ad do right here
we have five bills or let's see am I
looking at the right one four bills
no I'm looking at the wrong sheet
here uh
bye
bills and I'd like to open up for
discussion purposes for the HB
443 so let's turn to that bill and I did
have a discussion this morning earlier
before I had go to another meeting with
the folks over at
nhti with Shannon Reed working with Mark
Rubenstein Mark Rubenstein is the chair
of that particular uh commission um
regarding this Bill and as you recall
the bill reads terms the appointed
members on the commission we're talking
about except as otherwise indicated
above shall be for five years and it's
striking out and until a successor is
appointed in qualified vacancy shall be
filled for the unexpired
term we had discussion about that during
the hearing process and there was some
question as far as uh you know uh
um the people that are going beyond
their appointed time beyond the five
years but haven't been reappointed or
nobody else has been uh appointed
pursuant to executive councel and
governor and so those people continue
even though they're now living down in
Arizona and have nothing to do with the
college that they're supposedly supposed
to be representing on this
commission so um the question being then
uh where do we go with with this bill in
terms of trying to amend it to be more
clearly understood that you're going to
be representing that
college and attending meetings regularly
or whatever it may be and if you miss
for example hypothetically three in a
row or something without being an
excused absence are you kicked off um
and does that have to be put in
legislation or not um so I asked um I
talked with uh the folks at nhti that
share this thing because the remember
the chancellors are on this of the
colleges we also have the presidents of
the of of the uh colleges and then we
also have the private Council the
council uh uh M M M um what's his name
Stark um the Dartmouth College all the
privates in the state they also have
representation and they wanting to get
involved with this somehow
um so I I'm I'm going to open this up to
discussion right now if there's
questions let's try to get these things
answered they're willing to come over
and work with us on if we don't want
this is not an early Bill if we need
more information on that we can do that
um I just want to make sure that we're
understanding what the purpose of this
commission is what do they do and is
this something that Doe is going to have
be able to do in place of them um
I have concerns that Doe is not going to
be able to do that there's there it's
really comprehensive what they do in
reviewing those people want to come in
and open up a higher education
institution in this state it's very
complex and we're not doing it for
international schools as we once did
that was presented by uh Mr applebe so
it's open for discussion right now not
taking any kind of motions if there's
question yet repesent papovich thank you
Mr chair um since this is an executive
session I'll keep it really short I will
say that it seems
that this bill is not ready to be exact
and I'm fine just not really taking any
action right now and um creating a work
session and figuring out which way we go
from the work session but in terms of
one quick suggestion given that my
understanding is that the meetings are
regularly scheduled twice a year for the
commission if we are going to have a
number of unexcused absences that
trigger this probably the highest I
would support would be two because
that's already one year of the seat
basically being vacant
unofficially but again we can I'm fine
just waiting until it's time because we
we still have strategic directions to
decide on
this the the number of times they meet
really depends upon what they have in
their plate coming atams first those
people that are under review or on
conditional approval or those which are
coming for initial approval if they're
coming in for new initial approval they
oftentimes meet
monthly uh to review these applications
looking into the finances of the people
and also the uh the standards in which
their their staff that are going to be
working there are going to be bound to
so I I I like the suggestion just not
doing anything on it today it's not an
Ames first I I agree that uh it would
make sense to hold this
and have a work session and deal with it
but uh I would say that I think what
what's presented here is a uh very
narrow problem that relates to terms of
a particular category of uh the group
that is on the board here um and trying
to make that trying to deal with a
problem that Mak you know sounds like a
real problem and um so that's one thing
and that's what the bill presents I
think the broader question that has been
raised about the purpose of this
commission
and uh how it fits into the higher
education public higher education
Enterprise in New Hampshire is a a
question that's really not gerain to
this uh Bill and uh we can go into it
sure but uh it's it's going Beyond
what's presented here in the
bill and uh rep have yeah thank you very
much Mr chair and and um and you know
similar you know I I was having thoughts
very similar to what representative Ames
was just um um just
discussing um but I do think I mean I I
I agree with the um you know with the
thoughts that um that representative pav
Mueller put on the table in terms of um
maybe um you know not acting on this
bill today so that we can consider what
the larger uh situation and if a non-
gerain amendment can be introduced maybe
that's something uh we we would want to
hold a hearing on and move forward with
or not so but um but I I agree there I
don't think there's a reason to um to to
to act today on so what I'd like to do
is I'd like to put a small sub committee
together uh of folks which will like to
work with higher education the we've had
uh the uh chair of this
commission support that and we also have
folks from the privates which would like
to come in and and yes that's widening
the scope of what this bill is uh but we
have to first deal with this issue of
the vacancies and are they going to be
filled and are they working with all
those people or is it a few people the
college presidents making these
decisions uh if the other appointed
people don't
show and I don't know that I don't know
what the history of it is so I just like
to defer this action today put together
a small subcommittee to have them come
back um prior and have that report come
back to us prior to the date that this
has to be out of the committee has to be
out by March 20th so we would have a
subcommittee come back with a
recommendations to us and we go with it
there is there any opposition to doing
that not seeing any no I just wanted to
add a
comment go ahead I just wanted to say
that one of my concerns is the fact that
the governor is making these these
appointments and so I think we need to
look at the um regulations that are
related to governor and Council
appointments because maybe we can't
change it here it might conflict with
something that's there well it's it's in
our statute which we write uh that it's
done by governor and councel uh we can
change any anything we want that's in
there it's our prerogative so we're the
legislature we are a separate Branch
totally from the governor so those are
words that are music to my
ears okay so we're going to bypass on
this right now and go to the the next
bill which we had in the dock which is
484 and this is Rel to reallocation and
repurposing of Career and Technical
education classroom Space by local
school
districts here's what I got again from
the uh director of uh Career Technical
education this morning on on the
telephone on the cell
phone I understand and I've read the
information regarding where where
Milford is on this right now and having
to try to uh use this space which has
been CTE space for 20
years and then utilizing that space uh
going forward here in their uh
repurposing and use of that space um
it's he's he's of the opinion that if in
fact you have a space such as that
that's been used by CTE that you want to
have a general education class come in
and teach within that classroom
space it's okay if in fact you're still
using it on the other part of the day
for a Health Sciences class which is
wrapped up in those CTE clusters program
so it's a shared space that they said if
if if in fact you're going for that
grant money which you know would be the
$ 13.7 million which is a state share um
that of I think the total project Gary
if I'm wrong was around $28
million 23 and she's been reduced by the
state that's right so go down to 23 and
so you're looking at you know then the
9.9 having to come up from a local Bond
um that uh this
legislation
uh may not really have an impact one way
or the other on it other words there
he's saying if you're going to continue
to use it for CTE even though you're
going to be using it also for General Ed
and you have some uh deferred
maintenance in there they that's not
going to stop them from getting their
Grant they may you may be hearing
something different but uh so at at this
point in time that's what I got back
they're also saying over the doe right
now that there is a a group with the
responsibility of giving a report in May
of this this year dealing with how we're
going to do Capital Improvements and
looking at the programs and CTE right
now right now it's it's the always the
next two projects Milford and ringe Jeff
this this go around and then then we get
down to the bottom of the list here we
will be then starting a new process and
they're coming out with a report how to
allocate dollars to do that and uh that
that study group report comes out in May
as I mentioned and with there'll
probably be new rules and everything
associated with so we're going to be
just jumping how we do things here very
shortly here should we wait till then um
if this is imperative and that we really
need it to allow them to have a CTE
program I'm open to doing anything to
help a CTE program I'll tell you right
there I will always vote in support of a
CTE program so open for a discussion
yeah D
representative thank you Mr chair based
on your presentation it seems
that while you know this may not
necessarily be needed or solve the exact
problem there doesn't seem to be any
harm in just passing it and then
adjusting it based on the report of the
commission or what not in the next year
I mean I think I would rather do
something this is a rather innocuous and
harmless bill that may help I don't
think there is any harm in you know
oding it if needed and you know then
continue to survey the landscape and see
if more action is needed but I wouldn't
want to not do anything when something
can be done just to wait for more
day yeah
yes I I am of the
same um opinion as you that anything
that we can do to help help the CTE
programs would be something that we need
to do um this wouldn't just help the CTE
programs this also would help the
regular Ed programs I think that it's
that we can I think that we should um
put this through as ought to pass and
then wait for the committee report to
come out and next year if something
different needs to happen something
different needs to happen so I would I
would say the same thing as represent
said thank you yeah if if I'm
understanding the situation that conal
was facing um last this past fall when
they were looking at
expanding the way I understood it is
they wanted to build a new CTE Center on
the school and they wanted to move it
into a different location and they
wanted to repurpose their current CTE
Center for classroom space so this bill
would actually help them be able to do
that because I think as things stand now
they would not have been able to do that
and would have had to demolish that old
CTE Center and build a brand new center
so this would have preserved that space
to be repurposed for other things and
allowed them the ability to apply for
the the grant they chose not to at the
time but um or since but it would have
allowed them to be able to build a brand
new CTE Center and still preserve this
area MH
yes represent luno thank you um Mr chair
so
um in in some conversations I've had
with um with with a former CT director
outside of um the the committee room
although he has testified here before uh
there are there there are at least a
couple other situations across the state
involving CTE space potentially unused
CTE space in the need for um for
non-ct high school classes to or
interest among non-ct High School class
or High School courses to um to to use
some unused uh CTE space but I think um
from from from you know uh uh from the
conversations I've had not all of these
situations are the same and uh or would
be covered by the language that's in the
current um bill that's in in front of us
here and um and so uh and and and also I
think some of the the um
the I'm I'm I'm not sure how much this
committee um uh knows about what the
specific situation in Milford um is
either and and you know I'm just looking
at at a memo that I got from from the
former CTE director I he wres I asked if
they could explain something about the
chemistry Labs which he seemed to focus
on um then they mentioned a c biotech
room that the high school not CTE was
using initially built through the CTE
renovation build sponsored by the state
so so not quite sure where things you
know stand on the ground in Milford but
also in um I believe North Conway and
Claremont also have um situations that
need to need to that would like to be
addressed as well I I I in the
discussion today I had that discussion
with Mr beards and he said that if
they're going to be jointly sharing and
using that facility it's different than
a facility that you're taking over
totally for general education regular
education so what I did um last night I
I just want to get this clarified I did
write a blur for this bill OTP blurb and
I want to read that for everybody right
now to hear where I'm coming because it
says some of the things I think that
that town is trying to do uh and the
other one that's we're dealing with je
Jeff's ringe and that's a different
situation Jeff has gotten into the
business of doing some jaffre excuse me
jaffre um that's where Val is down there
and where they're having a smaller
program which is sort of a a a satellite
to what they've had before but they're
trying now to bring the seat te centers
into these high schools so kids don't
have this travel time and we're losing a
lot of scheduling and all that so I'm
going to read this quickly this bill
authorizes the school district to
repurpose Career Technical education CTE
space uh after 20 years of exclusive use
at no cost that's in the bill this
change to statute will enable the
Milford CTE Center to move forward with
their proposed CTE project each bium two
centers are designated at the state
level for CT renovation support funding
the Milford High School and applied
techn Technology Center project did
receive state approval but the initial
proposed state budget project renovation
amount of 28 million has been reduced as
uh represent uh uh uh um Daniels said to
roughly
23 uh this funding reduction has
resulted in milford's need to reduce the
project in size and scope therefore
repurposing current spa space I should
repurpose and use of the current space
the project includes a Motorsports
program facility SL classroom
Renovations and replace and replacing
outdated CTE
equipment in addition to State support
and local funds several Milford
businesses and nonprofit organizations
have pledged support for the renovation
project through in-kind donations of
equipment and more 21 Milford businesses
have written letters of support for the
project many which host students for
work-based learning uh I think this is
narrowing down to a singular project
until we get that may report done but
and I was also told by Jeff B beards
they probably will get that if they send
her application and they'll probably get
it anyways because they're seeing as a
shared area shared space for both uh
regular Ed and and CTE so um my
suggestion is we we move this thing
forward with not to
pass yes represent Damon thank you Mr
chair
so I just want to bring up for part of
the discussion and bringing this forward
because of a situation in Claremont
although I don't think it's Unique to
Claremont or likely to be unique in the
future and preface my remark by saying I
hugely value the CTE centers and the
need to get more students benefiting
from them however in Claremont there is
a situation where there is unused CTE
space because a program
closed the bill building is a short 5
minute walk from the high school which
is crowded they want to be able to use
the unused CTE space for General Ed not
shared with
CTE because they don't have a need for
that but actually separate for General
Ed so I actually frankly had intended to
bring forward an amendment and I
neglected to get to that but what I
would put out to the committee is and
ask for some consideration if you look
at lines seven and 8
if we were to remove the words if the
space is being vacated to enable
expansion of the Career and Technical
education program that occupies the
space if we remove those words then we
are basically saying space that has been
used by the Career Technical Center for
20 years can be repurposed by the
district so it leaves the district the
flexibility to use the space to the best
advantage of their students which is the
essence of local control
so I'd be interested to hear people's
feedback on
that feedback represent
McGuire thank you Mr chair sorry about
my voice
um I'm I'm in favor of that because I
think uh people's purposes change over a
long period of time right and so what
seemed like you know it was necessary 20
years ago you got to be able to have the
flexibility to rethink
at some later point so I I think that's
reasonable and when Mr beard said to me
this morning yeah it may not be using
now so you want to repurpose it for what
you just said represent McGuire but it
may be down 10 years from then that the
nature of CT has changed they want to
repurpose it back to CT I think they
ought have that ability to do
that that's a local
decision reps and
Damon so would it be acceptable to just
not take action on the bill this morning
I'll get an amendment drafted to bring
at when it's appropriate
scheduled any reactions from the
committee on that represent
papovich to be fair while I haven't
spent that kind of time on this that was
kind of the thought I had when I looked
at it it seems that after 20 years of
strings attached the school should have
the flexibility to use the space you
know 20 years is a long time things
change I don't want to micromanage and
try to guess down the road so personally
I would be fine with the if the space is
being vacated and so on until he
occupies the space being removed and
just leaving the it can be
repurposed further comment yes's
represent luno then represent fell yeah
thank you very much Mr chair yeah I'm
I'm good with uh with the idea of of of
um waiting for an amendment and then and
then taking action on this but but uh uh
in between those two things I think it
would also be um be good to get um um
director Beard's um um just feedback on
on the proposed amendment as well as
Steve Rothenberg who um you know deeply
involved in that I mean just to I've
spoken with represent be I I speak often
with Steve Rothenberg but and on this
one right here I think that we're I want
to see some kind of decision made now uh
as soon as possible seeing they're
looking at March meeting coming up as
well
um so if they can see this this
supporting CT and moving something
forward I think that will may help them
gather the votes that they need to do
this sure so um I'm just saying if we
don't exec today you know if we exec
this soon would be able to get the
amendment done and be able to get some
feedback if in fact we get an amendment
today and folks like that Amendment why
don't we uh take action on that later
today
yeah I mean sure okay so that I yes
represent could I ask representative
Damon just to repeat exactly which words
she would be deleting in the amendment
yeah of
course it
is line seven and eight and it would be
taking out starting with the word if if
the space is being vacated to enable
expansion of the Career and Technical
education program that occupies the
space so it's the last phrase of that s
it doesn't require a build exactly you
don't have to be expanding CTE to use
the space for other purposes that may
CTE represent C and then repres excuse
me represent fellows I had recognized
her earlier represent let's go across
there and then back to you so I just
wanted to confirm does anybody know
exactly what the federal requirements
are because these are built with partly
with Federal money these were not built
with federal dollars W just State
dollars they were built with State
appropriated dollars I asked that
question this morning okay and then in
that case I the part that's in here um
before um representative Damon's um
proposed amendment just the way it's
written now I don't understand what the
to yeah okay representative Co comp
that's well what I want clarification
noost Pap I believe it refers to the
requirement that if a school has been
built you would State money and you know
it's no longer used for the purpose that
the school would need to refund the
state for all or part of the building a
that is my understanding of the at no
cost language but again you know if we
can make a quick phone call to doe and
clarify that would be great but that's
understanding of it the the school
building Aid is a different topic but we
also have that phrase in there if if
you're going to do something with that
building within that 20-year period of
time you owe that State Building Aid
back to the state so we're we're
clarifying it here we got the same
20year rule in this so uh I don't think
that no cost makes any difference if you
got the 20 years already in there or or
or maybe it it does doesn't do any bad
to clarify it either so i' I'd leave it
purposes agree AG okay are we all good
to say to represent Damon go get a
Amendment on
that thank you I'm I'm willing to
co-sponsor okay okay so so we would have
yourself represent Damon and Mr
representative Maguire is co-sponsoring
that m a g u i r e mc mc you 5050 CH
okay great so we'll hang on to that and
get on to the next bill because we have
three
more
um here we are okay relative the
response via local districts to provide
transportation and meals for pupils in
I see there's an amendment for
that yeah I have a proposed an amendment
so let's have the discussion on this
first okay okay
right uh on on the bill
itself do anybody any more clarification
about okay do we have anybody making a
motion
on okay so what we want to do is have a
brief discussion on them then we're
going to break in the caucus no I'm not
taking any
motions can you please reverent McGuire
yes very simple the amendment removes
section two which is the section about
food but leaves section one which was
the section about
Transportation okay let's have some
discussion on that what he's doing is
saying that right now the law states
that a district shall provide
transportation for K through 8 and may
provide transportation to school for
grades 9 through 12 this came out of the
umberger report back in
2019 so this would now say that it's for
full-time
kindergarten uh shall provide
transportation for full-time kindergart
and we're talking about a halftime
program here so they would not have to
provide transp that's how I understand
am I correct on that represent McGuire
yes
discussion not see re
Damon thank
you so you all will not be surprised
that I do not support the amendment um I
think it's critically important to feed
children is very manageable for the
districts to have the morning and the
afternoon afternoon kindergarten
children overlap and feed them one lunch
together so the late kids came in the
morning kids haven't left yet it's also
good for their connecting and learning
from each other and building for their
relationships as they go into first
grade when they'll be all day together
um so I I do not think it is valuable to
remove the nutrition component represent
spsb I think removing section two leaves
the it is
yeah so it's the other way around so so
there's no change to
food
creation well bricky excuse me I did you
both have your lights on I I think I
what um Mr chairman could I pass the
amendment the around does everybody have
a copy of the amendment no okay can you
yeah this
audience repent McGuire can you explain
it so the main thing is you can see the
title has changed right so the title now
is only about Transportation so the bill
is only about Transportation it's no
food your Amendment your amendment is
Del food is already in law right so
already in law they have to provide food
I think I understand that but I'm sorry
Mr chair no I I recognize your
representation okay um amend the bill by
deleting section
two which is the
food section two is already the law if
words yeah so leave it as it
is so we're only talking about
bricky
so so what does it say about food it
says that we're going to feed them no
matter what the only reason I ask is
um because right now um there
are the opposed and the online testimony
is uh 19 opposed and only three support
I think that's what it was but um it
most of them talked about the food so I
think that that was I just want to make
sure that the the issue of the food is
still there and all the every single one
of the emails that I received about this
was really about the food so we're we're
sure that the food's still there repon
spelsbury yes you're correct so so the
current law makes no distinction
regarding food between half day and full
it's just pupil right all right thank so
we're leaving that
alone ref and Luna
thank you very much Mr chair so um so
getting rid of section two um looking at
just
Transportation if we're going with the
um the wording in the bill just in in
section one um am I understanding this
correct that that for for um halfday um
kindergarten students and so usually I
think halfday programs will be a halfday
program in the morning and a half day
program in the afternoon or full day
program that encompasses both those but
for the halfday kids kiddos they'd be
able to get a ride in in the morning but
no ride home um at noon or the the the
second half day kiddos would be able
would have to take a you know um you
know parent or guardian or friend to
drop them off you know at noon time and
they'd be able to catch a ride home on
the bus
but but um but there would be no no no
Transportation solution both
home to school and then school to home
for um you you'd get one half of that
but you wouldn't get the full um the
full Transportation that's what it says
that's that that's what that's what the
change all right represent
Co yeah thank you Mr chairman the way
I'm reading this is it removes the
requirement but doesn't necessarily say
that it's disallowed so the way I'm
interpreting this is that school
districts may still contract with a
busing company for their halfday
students for those rides but it's not a
requirement in law that they shall do
it that's
correct represent papovich to be very
brief it increases local control by
letting school districts decide whether
those programs for how they
kindergartens are needed or not some
districts may have very few kids and see
no point in you know running a bus for
three kids I'm pretty sure that wiam
will continue operating the buses the
way they do because we have a lot of
kids and it wouldn't make any sense so
really you know I don't want to provide
a top down mandate to every school when
fine yes represent
Amon first I apologize for my confused
remarks on the amendment which I am fine
with the
amendment however I'm not fine with the
basis of the bill in regards to
transportation we live in a state with
many many rural school
districts with many many parents who do
not work in the
community they don't have a feasible way
to get their kindergarten aged child to
afternoon
kindergarten without compromising their
capacity to be earning a living to
support the family because they're not
necessarily working in the community
there are many single family single
parent households where it becomes even
more complicated to do that frankly the
two years that my two daughters were in
kindergarten were the hardest years for
maintaining them being where they needed
to be getting to child care and two
hardworking parents trying to be where
we were supposed to be for
work I think it's not a very good
service for our
constituents the fundamental piece of
education is get the kids to the site of
Education I don't know why we wouldn't
support that uh does anybody know what
the definition of a full day
is um you whether I know there's number
hours you have to have each year a
number of days you have to each year um
when I've been a school principal it's
been if you stayed from the morning
start till after lunch that would be a
full day that's why on these snow days
they try to hold them in there as long
as they can so they get credit for the
full day am I right or wrong on
that okay so if you have your half day
kindergarten coming in the morning with
everybody else and going home after
right think so that's good
question well well it's considered by
Statute a full day or by rule so if you
have a full day so that would mean that
uh those students may get a breakfast or
but if you wanted them there through
lunchtime you couldn't do it if you want
to count them as as um or not provide
them Transportation you'd have to get
them out of there before the noon lunch
am I right or wrong represent luno so
it's a very good question Mr chair and
and maybe getting some clarification
from the Department to our our half day
kindergarten students
who let's say they receive
Transportation eat lunch and then go
home immediately after lunch are are
they a 0.5 ADM or are they a 1.0 the
after and whether that's considered a a
halfday program or a full day program
for virtue of of the 180 days or is it
um or or they considered a full day
student from the standpoint of
admr Mr chair uh attorney do you have
anything for us in
that is it wiser for us to hold on this
bill
for you know I'm looking over here to my
right prent papovich I would suggest
that for me personally given that it's a
local control thing I don't see a need
to wait but I will be happy to defer if
the majority of the committee would like
now we're gonna break for caucus we're
gonna have a caucus right now and come
back in about five minutes Mr chair can
we put one more piece of information in
that yes M Wilson is telling us that the
full day is five hours I believe the
so that would go from 8 o'clock to 1:00
right after lunch you got your
instruction remember in
kindergarten yeah well recess is
instruction in the kindergarten
Lev okay yes so let's take a quick
caucus here we will discuss and and then
come back in about five minutes uh
here
Pete have you looked up anything
relevant
have you looked up anything relevant to
this fil did you look up something
relevant to this yeah okay what what did
you find out what did I look up you
asking yes read
it I'm sorry yeah I'm so I'm I'm reading
I I've got two pages here but they put
out a page um from the Department of Ed
it says uh it's 450
hours they they break it down hold on
hold wait yeah make sure that we're
off supp to do it immediately as
well how do we
verify let's go
[Music]
online should have like a little red
light that
be we probably can't for that version
maybe if we make an LED the electricity
your
e
we're all back online and I'd like to
recognize repesent Maguire for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
ought to pass with Amendment no just
ought to pass right now to
pass we heard I need a second on the aop
pass represent
papovich you're Rec so for our clerk to
catch up with us represent McGuire made
the motion second by
papovich represent Maguire your do you
want to discuss your motion can I move
an amendment or yes okay so I'd like to
move Amendment
H is there a second represent papit
seconds
it so in a second when she gets this
done
okay all you'll just let me know when
you're good taking down the amendment
number so I'm going to go for it okay
rep Sam McGuire thank you Mr chairman so
I think this is a
quite a reasonable request um because
any children who are in half day
kindergarten necessarily have to have
adult supervision for the other half of
the day so
um that adult supervision should be able
to provide
transportation um and for for some
districts like the one that's requesting
this it's it's a very large expense with
not very much benefit so it should be up
to them what they decide to do represent
Pap you had the second do you have any
further
discussion any further discussion
represent fellows um yes I'm I'm fine
with uh removing the second part of
section of the bill but in in terms of
the first one I can't support that
because what it does is it puts parents
in a difficult situation when there's a
halfday program and if a parent uh the
if a parent is working and their child
needs to go to daycare for half a day
this makes it impossible to guarantee
that that that child can get to that
daycare center if there's no bus
transportation for that daycare center
that's within the district then um the
parent May well choose to just not send
their caught child to kindergarten at
discussion not seeing Madam clerk would
you please call the
role actually can we do just on on the
amendment hands on the amendment oh we
can do that too so all those in support
of the amendment and the amendment
number is
supportive supportive of the amendment
all those
opposed so it's
unanimous okay now we have the motion uh
would you please make a motion for
otpa represent
Maguire yes so
moved Mr second representative
otpa not yes repesent
luno thanks for much Mr chair so
um one of the things I think we've
learned in this committee is a a lot of
us have personal stories to tell because
at some point we were all connected with
schools whether they were Public Schools
or private schools or kids in public
schools or on school buses or eating
school lunches or everything everybody's
got a personal story uh to tell and and
um as to I so so um uh both our kids
went to uh went to public schools from
first grade through uh through 12th
grade and um uh but they didn't do
kindergarten in public school why
because back then Hopkinson only offered
half day programs and um my wife and I
needed a full day solution to um um uh
to kindergarten and um and in fact we
needed a full day solution that not only
started at um at between 7 and 8:00 uh
in the morning but also included an
after school program and I think uh you
know we may have gotten penalized a
dollar a minute if we were late pickup
after 6 o' but um but um but we were
both early in our careers at that uh at
that time and it would have been
absolutely impossible for us to um to
drop them off any later or pick them up
any uh any earlier uh than that and um
and uh uh but but it came at quite a
cost for us for us to do that and I
think back then the tuition was probably
I mean I don't remember what it was but
but you know we're talking you know it
you know tens of you know a $10,000
chunk um uh for that but it allowed us
to move on with our careers you know I I
just think about how how important that
opportunity is for for young families
and we want them obviously to to be able
to do the best they can for themselves
and for their for their kids but but if
if they're not able to uh to pick up
their kids or drop off their kids midday
uh or they're not able to get their kids
to an after school program because a lot
of these buses the bus now in Hopkinson
when it um when it um when it pick picks
up kids um to bring them home also stops
at after school programs to to drop the
kids off but if you're not able to um uh
to do that it's um and and and for a lot
of people too across the state
transportation's an issue and transport
personal transportation's an issue not
everybody has a driver's license not
everybody has access to uh to a vehicle
and uh not everybody lives um right next
to others that they might be able to
carpool uh in in a in a convenient way
but um but you know what we have here in
New Hampshire
is not compulsory attendance for
kindergarten we do have compulsory
attendance I think grades 1 through 12
is not required for kindergarten and for
parents that are that are going to find
a hardship to uh to to get their kids to
kindergarten or complete inability to do
that it leaves them with only one option
I don't think it's a good option for the
kid I don't think students I don't think
it's a good option for families I don't
think it's a good option for the state
cuz we know when when uh when when our
kids don't go to kindergarten that they
enter first
graded behind behind not ready so um so
I uh I I you know I I I just can't
support uh this what's what's left to
this bill and unfortunately I think
during the during the hearing and during
during comments the um the the
the everything seemed be focused on the
um the school meal the nutrition piece
and uh and not the transportation piece
had this bill just focused on
eliminating midday Transportation or
incomplete transportation for half day
kindergarten kids I don't think this
bill would be going anywhere further
discussion rapan
papovich I just want to briefly say on
the record especially for the Watchers
that may be confused that this bill does
not prohibit that transportation from
being provided schools that feel the
need for it will continue to do it
because it is allowed it mer merely
removes a mandate which is a burden to
the districts that do not need that
Transportation thank you and I will just
add a last comment in here that the
current law says no Transportation has
to be provided if they're within 2 miles
of the school but most districts do
provide transportation because they're
concern for the health the Safety and
Security of kids and so this is a local
decision and I believe that a local
school board will make the right
decision um to do the transportation one
last comment who wants to make that last
comment on your side FS good represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you
representative
bricky
providing Transportation midday for
kindergarten
children is cost effective
of our society because kids who have
kindergarten need less Services when
they enter first grade so for all the
reasons stated working parents health
and safety of children very valid but
truly this is an economic benefit to our
school systems it's not a huge sum of
money leaving it to local control is
defaulting to the halves and the Have
Nots again the communities that have
resources will continue to provide
transportation and those who are very
compromised in their local school
funding May well not I cannot support
this Bill thank you very much Madam
clerk would you please call the rooll
when you're ready the motion is on HB
319 as amended with Amendment
03458 uh and to pass the bill
otpa vice chairman SP bearing yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom
yes representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no Representative bricky no
Representative
no P
18 oh sorry uh yes chairman lad yes
Nays okay the next bill which we're
going to do is HB will there be a
minority motion oh yeah we'll be oh yeah
there minority and of course it's
regular calendar
and yeah thank
you HP4 747 stablishing a program for
enrichment scholarships for gifted
students and making an appropriation
therefore I'm going to hand the gabble
over to going to write The Minority
Report on that left though represent Dam
represent Damon was writing that yeah
that's what she said um I'm going to
hand the gavel over to representative
spillsbury
to so I can make a
motion okay I'm opening the executive
session on HB
747 and recognize representative lad to
make a motion I make a motion
itl it a motion is there a second no
second second from representative
luno a
discussion yeah very very briefly uh
when I'm looking at that fiscal note
where we're talking
1.19 million FY 26 and another million
in
27 uh we' We've looked at gifted
talented bills before and uh this is
coming very inexpensively for gifted
talented bills usually it's up closer to
$3 to $7 million
um and um it's it's uh I don't believe
this is the year which even though I've
always presented legislation in this
area of education and I think it's
important uh that this is not the year
to be expanding uh uh a program such as
this when we're looking at trying to
maintain what we currently are
doing any further comment
role Vice chairman bills baring
yes representative Maguire yes yes
representative Earth yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative
papic yes resentative Brown yes
representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricking yes representative chisan yes
yes representative Weinstein yes
chairman lad
yes
18 no zero nay the vote being 18 to zero
the motion of itln HB
747 carries um it's over a million bucks
so it's got to go on the regular
calendar okay regular calar it's it oh
itl yeah that's we don't have to because
it is itl very good is there any
objection to putting the bill on the
consent
calendar okay we'll go on consent and
lastly we have hb750 relative making
incentive grants for school districts
that improve in certain assessment
scores I recognize represent peoples for
a
motion chairman land thank you I'd like
to make a a motion to itl this
bill is there a second second represent
Damon makes a second on 750
uh represent peoples we'd like to speak
to your motion uh yeah uh with with the
current state of the budget and um the
shortfalls that we're looking at I don't
think this is a great year to start this
program um maybe sometime in the future
but um right now isn't the time
represent
Damon I think that's fine not hearing
any other
discussion Madam clerk when you're ready
would you please call the rooll and
750 itl itl Vice chairman spills Barry
yes representative MCU yes yes
representative B yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative poic yes representative
Brown yes representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricking yes representative kitan yes
representative Weinstein
yes and chairman lad
yes 18 y zero Nays any problems with
putting up consent not seeing we'll put
it on consent and that closes our
executive session for today what we're
going to do is take a 5 minute break and
now we're going to come back and start
the work sessions or the hearing the
hearing the hearing excuse me
that you want to clarify that
yeah
e
going to go ahead now with the couple
hearings which we have scheduled for the
latter part of the morning here uh HB
739 is the one up right now this is Rel
to excess funds paid to municipalities
for the use of school
districts and I'd like to welcome
representative spillsbury to the
education funding
committee well it's familiar territory
isn't it thank you
uh so HB
739 deals with the swept tax and the
situation of those communities that
collect more than they would be entitled
to receive an adequacy funding the
so-called uh donor towns in the the P
that was used before
2011 what the bill
does is it
reinstates three provisions of law that
were repealed in
2011 so as everybody I believe knows
prior to
2011 if a community uh realized
so-called excess swept it remitted it to
the
Dr and so the the principal um provision
here is uh three r numeral 2 and the
language added in lines 26 to
29 simply states that if there is an
excess Statewide education property tax
payment due uh then it has to be uh
remitted to the
Dr uh again this reinstates language
that was previously in the law on page
two it further stipulates that any such
funds that are remitted to the state
treasurer would uh be deposited in the
education trust fund and the third uh um
provision is in lines on
page uh one lines 19 and 20 basically
says that figure is then netted out uh
when determining uh the amount of the
education tax warrant so those are the
mechanics of it the purpose of the bill
was to put before the legislature the
uh streamlined surgical way of dealing
with the the problem and it's a problem
that's been discussed in the legislature
uh
repeatedly and of course uh we have a uh
we have a ruling of judge rof in the
superior court that the U uh retention
of excess swept is unconstitutional
because when it's all uh uh netted out
it creates uh uh inconsistent tax rates
across the
state uh you could be a betting man and
and you could uh you know take bets on
what the uh us the New Hampshire Supreme
Court's going to
do we could also wait to find out what
they do but I feel very confident that
on this particular part of Judge Rua's
rulings they're going to affirm and uh
and the legislature is going to have to
do something about it I just add you a
little bit of my own uh perspective I
think that this uh this problem
basically is a dilemma uh it stems from
the fact that we've chosen to provide
state aid uh you know under the adequacy
formula in part funded by the swept
which further assesses property tax and
when we do
that we we're going to do either one of
two things we're either going to allow
the towns that collect more to keep it
in which case I don't even understand
you know why have a state tax on
property that doesn't redistribute
anything you might as well just leave it
to the districts and communities to have
a higher local Ed
tax but the liability is if we're going
to have a swept tax then it does have to
be
constitutional we have other bills in
front of us that rearrange swept in a
variety of ways more than doubling it
that uh uh and and there are other bills
that also in one fashion or another uh
address this problem so I'm not I'm not
a fan of swept I'm very sympathetic to
the so-called donor uh towns uh but the
bottom line is if the swept uh tax stays
in law then it needs to be made
constitutional and this is the very
least that we should do if we don't
address it in some other Bill thank you
very much are there questions for
representa spillsbury
represent papovich and then represent
luno I not as much a question as much as
a thank you for bringing a very clean
bill so that the committee has a
potential tool in the toolbox if that's
the way we need to go I appreciate it
repr luno thank you so so thank you very
much and thank you very uh
representative spillsbury for bringing
this for I agree it is a very clean bill
and and I agree with your um with your
statements with respect to the the um
um how this if we're going to have a
state property tax that it should behave
like a state um uh behave like a state
tax but my question here is um is as we
as we go back towards um uh a a
situation where or condition where
excess weep is remitted so they you net
out your cost of inadequate education
school districts receive essentially two
um um uh
I guess they receive an estimate for the
cost of an adequate education by I think
November 15th of
the of the PRI year prior to the the
next school year they receive an
estimate of the cost of adequate
education and then later in the spring
that gets updated based on based on um
complete um admr uh information plus all
the differentiated Aid categories uh
how does the timing of of that work with
the with the remitting of the or with
the calculation of what's excess we and
the remitting of excess wept and if it's
not the same as what the actual cost of
an adequate education was as in that you
know that final calculation by the
department how would that get reconciled
so it's it's a very good question and uh
I know that Bruce caner is here from the
Dr and has a pin card in I have listened
to him give that explanation previously
and I don't I don't want to garble his
words so that would be great thank you
very much representative any further
questions thank you very much thank you
and so the next person is the other pink
card Bruce uh canor you're welcome to
take the chair and maybe answer the
question that represent Luna just asked
good morning chairman lad members of the
committee um sit there for the record my
name is Bruce canu I'm the supervisor of
the municipal Bureau at the Department
of
Revenue
um the timing uh question that just
occurred um as written this bill if
signed into law would take effect July 1
of this
year which means that we would be
calculating and preparing the swept
warrants for use as of April 1st
2026 um this
fall and in order to comply with this
bill's
Provisions we would need to know from
education um their
calculation of the ad y aid for a
um uh a district or what would be
effectively for that municipality so
that our warrant would then
include the language which had been
years ago on the warrants um identifying
the amount of the excess um swept tax
involved in the in the total of the
warrant so that calculation would need
to be
done uh by the laws regulating
swept Dr has until December
15 of 2025
to um have those warrants ready and and
forwarded uh we have worked with a
earlier deadline under the current
law so that um
the swept amounts were known in advance
so that education could utilize those
amounts in their construction of
adequacy
um I imagine that we would have to work
together on the
timing such that uh at first blush I
would
say Department of Revenue would
calculate the
total and then once education has come
up with that
estimate um we would then take that and
use it to
um create the warrants having
identified uh the excess
amount this approach was used um so we
have a sort of a historical model on how
to do it and and right now I think we
would just work with education should
this um bill become law to make sure
that the timing and the sequence of
events are laid out before we do
it so Bruce uh in looking at where we
are in terms of trying to look at our
total Foundation formula here and we are
getting some numbers right now uh from
uh doe regarding excess swep they're
projecting for FY
26 of the amount of 28,6 41,00
257 are are those good figures we should
be working around right now is that are
we in the ball park with the the amount
that they're projecting for for the
excess
sweat those numbers must have utilized
the um the swept warrant
that are ready for um this year FY 25
right yes
so I have no reason to say they aren't
um maybe education would want to weigh
in on on that okay um thank you are
questions for yes rent McGuire thank you
Mr chairman thank you for coming um the
fiscal note says that the cost of this
bill is $300,000 for your uh computer
can you explain why there's so much cost
here only in a very general way
representative because the rim system is
um not a system that the municipal
Bureau actually utilizes because
Municipal doesn't deal in in actual
Revenue so we we're not a part of it so
that estimate was developed by dr's
Administration knowing that
I think the rim system would have to
would require some alterations because a
new Revenue stream is being proposed in
this bill to come to Department of
Revenue here in conquer and that's all I
can really say uh we'd have to get
somebody else probably to identify why
the 300,000 is that
level further question yes follow up
thank you so um I'm following a similar
Bill somewhat similar Bill house bill
669 which we'll have a hearing at Ways
and Means tomorrow um and it does
something like this but in a different
way it simply says to all the
municipalities send in the check right
and and don't subtract uh the Grant and
is that is that approach have less cost
or is it roughly the
same um I'm not sure I I would imagine
that if the other bill and I think I'll
probably see you there um that other
bill will would require the rim system
to be adjusted as well so chances are
rep um I see that
you note that excess swept is not
defined uh and your this is the quick
note and uh
my question really is is that a problem
or not are you just noting that and you
say well we understand it anyway is that
what you're
saying yes I mean I think the uh history
is helping us understand what the intent
is
here further
questions represent
fellows uh thank you Mr chair um
are you the person who told us a week or
so ago about the when the um this swep
was for a short period of time was
collected are you the person that told
us about that the time frame yeah i'
have to check the tape but I think so
yeah so do you remember what that was it
was was it something like 200
2003 might have been the last
year I looked this morning to confirm my
thoughts at
2004 okay our records show the use of an
excess swept 2005 I used the same
Community to test it and it's it's gone
from the calculations so 2004 would have
been the last so so that that's my um
that's what I think it is too and the a
different figure keeps getting repeated
for when was the last time we we
collected the swep and my question
is the the Cal this might be more for
Education than you
but the there are changes when there are
changes made after changes made to the
adequate distribution right after well
after when the warrant amounts have been
set MH and after the
preliminary um estimates of adequacy
have been set
and I'm thinking that Dr is not going to
have enough time to know what the the
excess the excess is going to change
every time you change you take one
student out of the adequacy Aid
distribution and it CH could change what
the excess is depends where the you know
if it's in one of those towns and I
don't I'm wondering if you can if you
think that Dr can keep up with with
those changes to know how much needs to
be collected and
also isn't it fairly complicated to say
the amount of money that's collected
because that's different than the
warrant amount because we know that not
taxes if I understood your question is
whether
we could reissue
changes that's
right I don't know the answer to
that so it's a question I will try and
to I'm sorry I'm sorry with our adequacy
yeah I'm I put too many questions
together there's a lot in there and when
we unpack some of that that's collected
what several times during it's not
whenever there's a change of a
enrollment in your
school how this thing works it's State
Property the state so
um towns some towns bill by anually and
some Bill four times a year and you're
not going to know what the excess is and
you're going to have to keep changing
those amounts maybe and and plus not
everybody pays their property tax so U
representative fellas you've created
like three-dimensional uh chess here in
terms of what's going on um in terms of
changes to adequacy I have seen now this
is
legislative and I think it's probably in
the budget Bill if something changes
then the districts have that opportunity
to uh hold a meeting and
appropriate or consider a change based
on on
um the legislature changing an amount in
mid sort of in
Midstream as for um the impacts
of I don't I haven't seen that in terms
of adequacy payments being different
based on changes in real life student
enrollment and so forth uh affect
issued right well the the warrants under
this bill would carry an amount of
excess if there was one identified on
the warrant
okay and that number right now to me
stands as to whether or not the warrants
would have to be reissued because
somehow the excess amount has changed
that's the question I have to find out
if that's um something we've ever done
if we could do it um so that I will try
to get a answer back to the committee on
on that
question and the collection portion I
don't speak to in terms of well the
goalposts keep moving and you never can
get
them U I do have one question for you
when the municipalities asked to remit
this money back to the state yes is
there any processing fee that the
municipality would charge for remitting
this calculating and and and processing
it back to the
state the bill doesn't address any fee
and I would imagine municipalities would
have to determine whether they have the
authority to charge one on a state tax
which I don't know the answer to I know
there have been other bills I think last
last year last session one that
addressed that question but this bill
does not so um I don't know definitively
whether or not there could be but this
bill doesn't mention it that answers it
Bruce further questions from the
committee yes representative luno thank
you very much and and I think it's to
the chair because I I was just sort of
looking at the at the the date that are
contained in the in the bill and what
you've been talking about Mr canu and
and
and I've I've got down here sort of
November 15th is when the Department of
Education prepares their preliminary
cost of inadequate education right so
that would be used in the calculation
you're talking about 1215 which is when
you issue the swept warrant deadline
deadline deadline right for swept
warrants including the calculation of
excess swept but it would appear that
would appear to be a preliminary
calculation at the time and then and um
and and I know Miss Davis is here from
the Department might be able to fill in
when the final you know firmed up cost
of inadequate education is defined
probably sometime between December and
March and then you've got March 15 which
is when the municipalities have to
deposit um the excess to the state
treasury a year out again um if I might
oh oh so this isn't all in the same six
window this is
yeah I I'll describe first the way it
exists currently okay
um while the two laws would appear to to
um be in sort of um tension in other
words education needs a swept amount
currently to help identify
adequacy Aid there's a
relationship it it it was only a few
years ago we realized that the state law
for the
swept the deadline is after the time
when education's trying to prepare
something so at Dr we said well we can
do the calculations and produce the
swept warrants and we've aimed for the
last few years for toward the end of
September we have until December 15 but
we do them in September and distribute
them so that those the swept dollar
amounts are available to education in
plent of time for them to work on that
initial adequacy Aid
calculation
bill it it would appear to me that we'll
still go first at drra we're going to
calculate the swept dollars in the same
methodology as we do and provide
education with them so they can turn
around and do the adequacy aid
calculations determine if there's an
excess between what the swept amount is
what the adequacy initial estimate is so
that we then would be able to produce
the warrants which will now have the two
numbers we already know the first one
but we can't figure out what an excess
is education would they'd have to tell
us so I'm thinking the timing is going
to be very similar we're going to do it
early hand those numbers off but we're
not going to produce the warrants as
early as September we're simply going to
do the calculations which we can do
usually starting around June
1st under the current Arrangement now
under this law let's assume for a second
there's no changes as representative
fellows was describing we go through
that um sequence the warrants are issued
those warrants would be for April 1st
2026 and would be part of the tax rate
setting in the fall of
2026 if there's an excess to be
collected and identified in the warrant
it would be due in this law in by March
2027 that's in the second to last
sheet forther
questions thank you very much you're
welcome um I don't have any other pink
cards on it uh obviously this is going
to join all the other bills and we're
going to have a wonderful discuss
on that uh later par
me yeah so what we're going to do is
close this hearing see I don't have any
further pin cards on
739 and we're going to move into the
last
one for the day which is
729 making appropriation to the
Department of Education for an attorney
to rec codify the education
laws thank you very much and we have two
cards here
here all righty so representative Hill
you're up
and Caitlyn Davis on you're on Deck
thank you Mr chairman for the record I
am representative Greg Hill Uh current
chairman of legislative Administration I
represent the town of Northfield uh
maram 2 um
real simple Bill I'm hoping
um we've had this bill in the pass uh it
has been passed through the house
and then was referred to the uh to
division two of Finance um they retained
it uh I'm not sure really how far they
they went in that process um perhaps
Miss Davis from doe can fill you in on
that part of the process um that bill I
think requested 80,000 I think think uh
at some point it's been bumped up now to
100,000 to rectify or begin the process
of recodification of our education
statutes um no one Beyond uh chairman
lad can tell us uh how just just how big
a problem this is um we've all
experienced uh those of us that have
been here for any length of time have
experienced the problems within the
education statutes and duplication and
uh contradiction in some cases um it's
certainly something we need to do and
we've been kicking this can down the
road for quite some time so um with that
I will uh end my testimony I'm not sure
if there's any real need for questions
um I think those would be best handled
by uh by uh Miss Davis of the of
doe but I will attempt or or deflect I
know you're very good at answer asking
questions on this committee I don't see
any hands thank you so thank you very
doe good morning Kaitlyn Davis from the
Department of Education um so this bill
um really started when representative
Hill was at the Department of Education
for a public school infrastructure
meeting of all things and we were trying
to look up several things and finding
trying to I think we were trying to
determine certain definitions of who
might be eligible for public school
infrastructure funds and you're trying
to use various definitions and saying
well this conflicts with this conflicts
um and so we were saying it would be
really helpful if we could have a
recodification of education laws um the
laws in this book some of them have been
on record for over a hundred years and
that means many of them are outdated um
or don't necessarily make sense or when
they were written obviously the
processes that we have in place now
could have never even been conceived in
people's minds you know especially with
technology that we have um and so we
really Envision um a recodification of
the law to really just go through and
find different areas that need to be
clarified different areas that conflict
different areas that need to potentially
be updated there are um areas of law
that still require say a paper report to
be submitted to the Department of
Education which doesn't necessarily make
any sense for why we're having people
use paper now um there are other areas
where it's easy for the Department of
Education and the department of revenue
for example to share data and
information now but it requires a school
district to submit something both to the
Department of Education and Department
of Revenue and we want to make sure that
we're using best um the best systems in
place and you know best use of people's
times there's actually one um that uh
Bruce and I were talking to this morning
about an email we found an area where uh
something has to be submitted to both
the doe and the Department of Revenue um
and we said well do they submit to you
separately and we were trying to figure
out why why is this need to be done um
you know there's a lot of places in law
that unfortunately conflict um or maybe
terms have ch changed over the years and
so we're using older terminology that
doesn't necessarily tie to the practices
that we have today um you know a simple
one that I can think of is you know if I
say the the word public or sorry if I
say the word private school most of you
know what I'm talking about and the word
private school does appear in law I
actually think it's on a in a bill
that's on the docket this week for I
don't know if it's the policy committee
or this committee but it talks about um
something that private schools have to
do well we actually don't technically
have private schools in the state of New
Hampshire we have non-public schools
that's the terminology that we use um
and so clarifying that would be very
helpful um another really good example
um if you remember a couple weeks ago
when attorney Fenton did well she did
that I guess she did her presentation
for the policy committee but one of the
things that she mentioned is Charter
Schools when you're writing a law you
have to write into the law that you want
a charter school to do something
otherwise they're exempt relative to a
law in RSA
194b that's a great example because
there's a lot of laws on the books that
have been on the books historically that
say all schools have to do this but then
with that reading that with the other
law that says charter schools are exempt
unless it specifically says Charter
Schools people think that charter
schools are doing whatever that
requirement is but it's not because that
all schools was on the books since like
1970s Charter Schools were the
legislation enabling them was written in
the
1990s um so there's a lot of examples
like that I mean another example I just
looked up real quick RSA 193 says the
Department of Education May collect
student addresses for the purpos of
assessment reasons and then RSA 18968
says the Department of Education shall
not collect addresses
um and so really you know this is a
collection of laws that has been written
by a large uh number of individuals
through a long period of time that
really needs to be gone through in a
thoughtful manner um Rewritten
recodified um not even to we're not
talking about changing the laws we're
not talking about saying you know really
making political decisions we're really
just saying these are technical
Corrections Alone um and the department
has you know started process piece by
piece we are working on right one right
now a proposal around the charter school
laws to try to update those I know
representative fellows has sponsored
bills over the last couple years for the
Department just to change different
reporting requirements and whatnot so
we've been trying to do it piece by
piece but it makes sense to have a
larger whole whole project done to do
this um relative to uh what
representative um Hill talked about as
far as the process so this bill was
passed out of Ed fi uh regular education
um about three years ago it was included
it went over to finance um Finance had
come up with a proposal which we felt
was a really good proposal division too
as part of the budget process um which
was because this concern with the
funding if that's enough which was have
the Department of Education uh do an RFP
to have this work done and then come to
fiscal committee with that proposal and
fiscal could have the authority to fund
it or not to fund it um in our
recollection of finance and
representative Murray um just said she
just said to me didn't we pass this out
of Finance everybody remembers it being
passed out of Finance but it didn't end
up in the hb2 proposal that left the
house over to the Senate um so we don't
we don't really know what happened to
that proposal um then last year outside
of the budget uh cycle the Senate did
take this up um a bill at his own
because it had been retained by um
education initially and um the Senate
proposal that they put together was a
little complex and the house did not end
up concurring with the Senate's proposal
which included a fair number of
committees and whatnot which I don't
believe really needed to be done in the
preliminary work now maybe at the end
result of the work and you know what
ends up in the law a committee could be
helpful but not in the initial phase um
I think the only other thing that um you
know just so I don't upset our my
counterparts and state employees ol has
a heavy hand in this um and wants to be
included in this process so I do think
that we could um we could suggest that
the department of education does an RFP
in collaboration with OS um to ensure
that they think um the right resources
um are assigned to doing the initial
work um and I know OSS obviously um
wants to be very involved in what the
end product is and and they said you
know it's going to take quite a bit of
Staff time to actually write it and
reformat it and do all of that work once
we have the product and they wanted to
make sure that you know that was part of
the conversation but I think that's
really phase two phase one is just
really getting the RFP in the initial
proposal and all of the areas identified
that need to be addressed
so thank you very much um it's a real
needed Bill let me tell you in between
calling a curricular co-curricular
extracurricular exactly pupil vers
student uh there's so much confusion in
these statutes they need to be cleaned
up um hopefully we can get that going
questions represent luno then represent
McGuire thank you very much Mr chair
thank you very much Miss Davis for
bringing um for for being here and
talking about this um a lot of the
things you talked about seem to suggest
that maybe different language might be
necessary like if we want to do an RFP
to uh have um have joint fiscal
essentially be the appropriating body
yes um for this I also wanted to to
maybe poke on line 14 of the bill which
talks about the work should be completed
by September 30th 2025 that's right
around the corner I think that's the
original bill from two years ago when
representative Hill wrote it the first
time and I think they just carry forward
that date but so maybe that's a 2027
type of I think so so representative
Hill reached out to me over the summer
he said I was thinking about putting
this bill back in are you supportive I
said absolutely um but I did say you
know I think we'll probably talk about
the process and how it and he said yeah
that's perfectly fine so okay great
thank you this is another note this has
been proposed by Attorneys at OSS for
years and we have several recently
retired attorneys over by the name of
Anthony and Jeff I won't give their last
names which have really wanted to see
something happen here because every one
of us comes in there with these ideas
and we try to throw them in a law not
recognizing there's something that
counters it over here and we have a very
a huge book that's now full of conflicts
I usually start this testimony by
dropping the book on the table it makes
a really good prop for this but wasn't
wasn't into that today but so
representative McGuire then represent
Pap or papet or spelsbury one of the
other do you have do you have an sorry
do you have an estimate for how much
thinner that book will be after this I'm
sure you would go ahead and make it
pretty thick white right again so but
follow
up yeah how much attorney time does
$100,000 buy it doesn't seem like enough
that's exactly the conversation that was
had last time and so um when
representative Hill initially proposed
the bill we he literally just spit ball
and number $100,000 round number and
that's why we said it's probably not
enough appropriation that's why and
that's with the conversation we had with
the division too was how about the
Department of Education put out an RFP
for this because there's companies that
are out there that do this work um and
but who knows you know a proposal this
large um and that's why they wanted us
to come to fiscal with the RFP to
request the so basically if we modified
the bill or amend the bill to allow the
Department of Education to or require
the Department of Education to develop
the RFP in consultation with OS and then
gave the fiscal the authority to
appropriate funds to an RFP that you
know obviously would be a decision a
fiscal but we would come to with a
request and he would appropriate the
funds for that work we would if you then
chose to appropriate the funds we would
then um go to governor and Council to
finalize the contract just one more
please thank you is there a
self-contained section that we could say
get Rewritten and then have experience
in re redrafting that section and then
could estimate the rest of the job so I
think the challenge with that is is that
the sections all bleed into each other
so much it's really challenging um I
mean the charter schools is a great
example so the charter school law really
really needs to be re Rewritten um
because what There Was You Know local
charter schools and rather than you know
writing a separate section of local and
state it was all kind of written on top
of each other which was written on open
enrollment School schools which is a
conversation you all have been had
having as well um and so we've been
doing that um kind of when we have time
in the officing like oh here's this
here's this but then oh well there's
also charter school requirement in
building Aid there's also a charter
school requirement over here and and so
it's it's challenging I mean you're
going to see pece by peace mail
proposals from the Department over the
year because it's something that we are
trying to do as we can get to them but
not not
really um represent no okay representa
spilsbury in first he he just waved off
no no I'll go next par me I'll go next
no okay and then represent fellows thank
you who I thought he was waving off yes
my question was basically Mr M okay then
I would like go
ahead um
so when laws are enacted and there's an
enrollment process and then ultimately
there's codification which rearranges
them but where we're trying to rec
codify an entire volume of laws there
there will be undoubtedly many many
changes to the statutory language that
would be required so ultimately this has
to come back to the leg in yeah yeah no
the department can't make laws as much
as we like
to okay so so the the concept of course
is not to change the thrust or intent of
any of the laws but to Simply
reconstruct them so so that they're
clearing and consistent absolutely and
so the end result of that would
ultimately be and this would be you know
so the department would do its work we
would have a proposal we would work with
the OS to you know that's why they said
they might need additional resources to
completely Rec codify it in their style
and then we would come back probably to
the chair of House Education um to say
will you sponsor this bill and we
absolutely anticipate probably a
thousand page Bill to rectify the entire
thing it's it will be it will be giant
but it and it probably to my knowledge
as the first of this kind at the
department of or the state of New
Hampshire other agencies have certainly
talked about needing to have similar um
have similar processes done so we could
maybe the state could cut its teeth with
the Department's proposal but we'll find
out thank you you've confirmed what I
imagined represent fellows thank you um
I I know this has been an issue and a
you know something people have wanted
for more than a decade so I'm I'm just
concerned that um $100,000 doesn't get
you very far and I'm wondering if you
have an idea about what could
be the first step or one part that we
could actually see results from so that
we don't just get an RFP that just
writes the next RFP for what needs to be
done so I mean I I think ultimately we I
think we just do an RFP for the full
amount and we really see what those
proposals look like until we have an r
and and you know the end results might
be that of an RFP that nobody thinks
it's a proposal worth going forward but
I think we need to do that we need to
get that information out there and see
what that's going to look like um and
then have the department work with the
legislature to see if that's the steps
you want to follow um if not then we
need to have a public a conversation of
is there an additional staff attorney a
temporary full-time position at OS that
could potentially be doing this work or
what does this actually look like but I
concur with you that $100,000 is not
very much and we would not get very much
probably for $100,000 proposal but we
have to start somewhere and that's why
we really suggested that let's do an RFP
see what the total dollar amount is we
won't put a $100,000 price limit on the
RFP we will come to fiscal and say you
know please appropriate additional money
so you could take out the appropriation
entirely in an amendment of this bill
and just say do an RF Department do an
RFP bring that RFP to fiscal and let's
what that looks like and we could you
know you could if you want to um in
Amendment suggests the department um
have the RFP use some sort of phased
approach we could certainly do that my
concern with a phased approach though is
you know what I said to representative
McGuire is that because it's so
intertwined if you said just look at
another you know another great example
are the invent the data system
inventories I can tell you at least four
sections in law every time somebody says
oh can you do this with data I have to
look here here here and here and that's
not even all of the places where it says
that so I would be really concerned with
if you just did you know a small section
of law that you'd be missing some pretty
critical P pieces that are spread in
another section of
law yep so what I'm thinking is that
that could be an example of how you
start with you know just like a smaller
project which even that might you know
the example to like look at the charter
schools and and propose something for
what to do with those in the data
collection or you know just like two
pieces and that you might be able to
straighten out that part of it because
to do the whole thing is going to take
multiple people multiple years
so but we got to understand that they're
all linked I can look at the military
compacts which we have and I and talking
about special education and they're all
cross interl and if this we're going to
do it it's got to be done we can't do
this peace meal so it's going to cost
some
bucks uh represent Dame and then
representative uh Burton thank you Mr
chair thank you for helping us with
this
um so two things you gave some very
helpful examples of why we would need to
do this and spoke about technical
corrections but also about the potential
for a thousand-page bill of statutory
changes and it seems to me from some of
the examples are cited and just logic
that given that there's contradiction in
the statutes like your example of um
addresses student addresses being
collected or not that it's definitely
not just working towards technical
changes there must be many that would it
be correct that there are many changes
not just technical so we probably we
need somebody to come up with a proposal
to identify conflicts that might
actually and you're right that is that's
a political change like do you want the
department to have addresses or not well
you know if I just look at the
assessment law and I don't look full
picture I can go ahead and go collect
them because I would say I'm following
the law and my assessment team who
really just consecrates on the special
the assessment law might think that they
have the authority to to do addresses um
so um but you are right that there are
going to be decisions that need to be
made as part of the ultimate um Bill be
because of the areas that conflict yes
yes well yes thank
you are there other states that have
taken on such a substantial
recodification and if so can we learn
from their experience so I'm not aware
of that but I haven't done any Research
into that as well um I do think that OS
um had some information OS I was
actually expecting them to be here today
um because they have a lot of thoughts
and opinions on this as well um but um I
think ol has talked about other states
doing it or maybe knowing people that
have done it there's definitely
companies out there that do it if you
Google it real quick you can find
companies so it's clearly a service
that's needed and I'm guessing um you
know they could tell you what states
they've worked with I don't know if it's
education specific um you know the
federal government does it fairly frequ
not frequently but for example you know
they rewrote No Child Left Behind into
the every student succeeds act um and
that was essentially just a
recodification
um there were obviously many changes
that were made too but that was a base
law that is was kind of started and and
worked on so it's definitely something
that you know in our you know our
Attorneys at the Department of Education
if we had more of them they could
probably do that too if you know Liz
Brown and Diane Fenton both work on
these all of the time that they do not
have the capacity to do that so um if we
had a full-time attorney at the
department that focus on that I mean
there's there's a a variety of different
ways of getting this done um but really
I think we need to do is all accept that
this is not great the way it is right
now and we cannot continue to move
forward because we're just continuing to
build on a foundation that is really
weak um and we got to draw a line in the
sand and say we're going to make these
improvements going
Burton thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um having been
out of the legislature for six years I
was really impressed when an AI reviewed
thousands of pages of testimony and came
up with a simplified
model instead of making Robo calls to
everybody is it possible that an AI
could take this on objectively go
through the thing and then spit out
where the yeah I mean I think that um AI
is definitely a tool that could be used
here um but it it needs to be guided by
somebody and the department does still
doesn't have the staff and capacity to
guide that so A proposal from a um a
vendor certainly could um start off with
using AI to do a lot of this work and
that's a great tool that's been
developed even in the 3 to four years
that I've been after this that wasn't
available four years ago
but representative cocom and then
representative Ames did you have your
hand up yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question you mentioned
before and this has been something I've
been a little bit curious about um you
brought up we no longer use private
schools we use non-public schools and I
I've noticed a recent we Chang
superintendent to be senior education
official so I'm curious are we changing
those through the law is that's what's
happening to the these changes did we
change um the superintendent title to be
senior ex um education official through
law and that's what's creating the
conflict that you're finding here so the
non-public schools are absolutely that's
in law that we use the term non-public
schools in law um relationship to the
superintendent um title I and the senior
education official I believe that's in
rule but I mean rule is also a type of
law that's passed through Del car um but
a state board of education role oh yes
so with that example is that creating a
conflict because I think we can have
some school districts with a
superintendant and some without right so
should we not be identifying that as
we're talking about our so well right
now we're not talking about the rules so
in theory you have the laws which you
know authorize the Department of
Education or whomever to do something
and then you have the rules that provide
further definition and Clarity to the
law that's the way the rules should work
and so um if a law says um you know all
non-public schools shall do this and
then the Department of Education were to
have a rule that then said a non-public
school is defined as a private school of
this and this you could have kind of
those definitions at work um the law the
rules the CATE Board of Education rules
would absolutely need to be updated
after this is recodified as well so
that's step two um but step one is
really making sure that the laws
themselves make sense and so you're
correct so there's sections in law that
are confusing because there's sections
that say a superintendent shall do this
and then there's other sections say a
superintendent or the design shall do
this and then we have the other section
of law that talks about superintendent
services and is it I you know is it
clear that somebody can use
superintendent services for something
when it says specifically a
superintendent though those are all
great examples of the things that we
struggle with on a very regular basis
when trying to you know ensure that our
constituents have answers to what
they're required to do thank you last
fall thank you because that has been my
concern when I saw that new title come
in I couldn't find anywhere in law where
a senior education official is in our
law so I was concerned about why we went
with that title at the Department of
Education when we specifically have
superintendent in our law so and I think
the question on that with the senior uh
education official is more a question so
I haven't I'm on the rule side of things
I I need to actually go back and read
where it says that in the rule but I
think we also need to understand when
the Department of Education is trying to
Define who can do what as far as system
work so is it only a superintendent that
can certify this report and what happens
if a school district doesn't have a
superintendent at the time so a great
example of this is on July 7ish every
year schools have to certify a large
amount of data to the Department of
Education um that is used for
calculating adequate education grants
and everything else um when we do that
there have been times and there's
probably a few every year where there is
not a superintendent employed by by the
school district at that time and so who
has the authority to do that is it the
Schoolboard person or chair or is it um
is it an assistant superintendent if
they have assistant superintendent and
so you kind of using some of those that
same terminology has been helpful to the
department um and we're kind of working
on how that impacts our reporting in our
I have no doubt that this is uh a needed
project and I also have no doubt that
it's extremely complicated and uh will
take
time um to identify quote duplication
duplicative statutes and need for
consolidations
um a concern I have is that you've met
mentioned OS on several occasions as
needing to be involved wanting to be
involved um but there's no mention of ol
in the bill so I I think um so this is
the original bill that representative
Hill put in a couple years ago that
initially caused some concerns and some
alarms for OS and that's why I'm making
a point to bring them up because we are
saying we want to work collaboratively
with them and Os I think is initial
concern when they saw this bill was they
thought the Department of Education
wanted to do this on an island and not
concern them um um and so when you know
I I went and actually met with Terry
paff and a representative from OS and
said no we want to do this in
collaboration and we've had those
conversations then so what you have in
front of you absolutely needs an
amendment um and you probably needs to
change that $100,000 it needs to add you
know if if you guys want the fiscal
requirement needs to put that in there
it can say the Department of Education
will do an RFP in collaboration with OS
all of that is information that could be
added in here we need an amendment to
this this is the starting ground um and
hopefully we can get to something that
we can actually get past and start to
implement so I'm not sitting here in two
years or four years or eight years
having the same conversation I follow
yes that's good um and I would just
underscore that it's not just
duplications and
contradictions um and
consolidations its recommendations for
proposed legislation responding to
that material which is where policy
questions and judgments creep in and um
I would particularly want to see not
just the commissioner of the Department
of Education receiving and acting on
that but also
OS yeah perhaps something else I agree
with you yeah I mean I think that's
that's definitely part of that's going
to come out of this is the policy side
of things so okay just to just to close
this thing up th this whole idea when I
started hearing this years ago was
coming from
OS they're the ones and now what we've
lost is the history over there when it
comes to education now we have new folks
there when I used to walk in with stuff
and I was talking to
Anthony he knew where everything was and
he knew this is a conflict what are you
nuts he say to me you're putting it in
the wrong place you're looking for the
duties to the board you can find the
duties of the board all over the place
in there so it's hard for the public to
find out where things are located as
well we need to do this but you're right
this is going to have to be
Rewritten dealing with you know we're
going to put this thing out and trying
to figure how much money it's going to
cost we need to look at the OS involved
them very much in this uh so uh I would
suggest that we work hard on an
amendment and then move it forward uh
because every moment we're losing time
we're losing the history and we've had
people leave all us saying boy I'd love
to have a shot at correcting this but
you know they're too now getting engaged
in other stuff and we're losing that
expertise we need it so thank you very
much
for there what yeah represent luno thank
you very much M Mr chair and um and so
so since we are based on what you're
just saying looking for we'll look to do
um how do you want to proceed in terms
of uh discussing what could go into um
that Amendment do you want to do a a a
work group or a subcommittee uh on this
and try get let me put it to the
department right here too um Caitlyn you
just been given a pretty good overview
of what's right and what's wrong with
this is it possible before we put a
subcommittee together that a boiler
plate proposal could be put together
bring it back to us and then we could
that gives the subcommittee a place to
start working rather than our having to
explore all this again you deal with
this daily like superintendent you can
find where you have a single
superintendent in District it might be a
guy with a master's program with
expertise a master's program that's
related to school finance and those
issues that are required they don't have
to Neally be a superintendent that's in
law already so it's it's complicated
so can you do a boil plate for us of
what you've discussed today the proc for
the amendment just the amendment process
for getting this moving yes okay yeah it
would be like a like a framework yeah
yeah a guideline for us to start working
a framework it's good idea yeah and so
then we get that and we we'll come back
and look at that and if we have to make
additions subtractions whatever but
it'll allow us to move faster on
it any further questions yes yes I just
want to say that um there were some
changes made to to
rules the rules Pro not particular rules
to the rules process was made um in E
Edna worked on that and and I think that
that
maybe and and they rewrote a Hu the huge
you know practically everything that had
to do with with making putting rules
together and I just think that maybe
that would provide some in Insight that
the process if you can find out the
process that was used to put put that
together I mean you have to identify
what you need to do first well rules
Come From This which we want to rec
codify so so it's it's not contradictory
throughout they're not going to be
rewriting Statute in terms of what we
should have that's not their job so you
know what what's been done through gel
car in in improving
rules is our responsibility you know and
if we've done something which is
incorrect it's on us uh so I I I think
that what we need to do is do this first
step here to get this thing going and
that's where the boiler plate if you
bring forward to us the framework so
then we can move from there um we don't
want to have too many cooks in the
kitchen on
this it'll go forever so any further
before I close this thing down well
we're closing down uh 729 and thank you
very much today coming over um this is
heck of a job if we take it
on it's
huge it may save money in the long
run yeah
yeah thank you much so we have in this
afternoon folks what time you want to
all let's see I'm trying to find my
sheets
here oh yeah we got to come back a
little later that because this is on us
in the
afternoon uh yeah we'll come back at one
one
o'clock you need to slip to 105 go for
you
e
okay we need to get this thing going
here we're a little bit
behind and for the afternoon we have
broken our our conversation into two
areas
uh first one is dealing with the bills
which are referencing the meal programs
and the second part is starting to get
us into the conversation on uh special
education
funding so I'd like to start right off
with we have 583 646 and 665
703 which are all bills which are
referencing the meals program let's
start off with the first one that's
listed there 583 and that's relative to
the Medicaid director certification
program for free and reduced uh School
meals uh so if you have 583 that's the
one we're going to be looking at you
up the bill has been introduced so we
should know basically what that bill
does so uh we're in a work session right
now um if we have technical support here
uh and if there's Henry lintman now you
you're here I see so uh perhaps do you
1:30 so are you here to speak on this
583 Bill providing technical
support that would be Li okay so why
up now this is not the type of thing
where we have to have pin cards like
that okay
so uh are there are there questions uh
for the this is Medicaid direct if you
have a few information points you want
to convey to us you can do that uh and
then we can go from there sure for the
record um Henry Litman the state's
Medicaid director um I think uh what I
can offer to you is whether um a
Medicaid application um could have a a
designation on it a parent could choose
to whe they wanted to enroll their
student and free and reduced lunch or
not um if assuming they wanted to we
have the technical means to transfer
that application information over to the
Department of Education um and
conversations with with Department of
Education I believe they have the
ability to accept it and to to read it
that's about as far as as I can provide
technical assistance on terms of the
policy or whatever the it's really do we
have the ability to you know modif our
Medicaid application with a with a
checkbox type of situation yes we do and
can we transmit it I think in a form
that's readable by the Department of
Education that's also a
yes question clarification for everybody
here this bill has come before us before
in fact it came back in front of Karen
umberger's group years
ago the question was how do they get
permission from the parent to release
this information to another
agency how do you do that so we would
propose a a check the box kind of
situation where they could choose
whether they want to have it referred or
not um and so that would it'd be that
kind of simple process they'd have to
make an affirmative election on their
[Music]
application yes uh
represent is this kind of check the box
process use in other states are you
aware of what other states are doing in
this regard I'm I'm not familiar as to
whether um whether that's how they
transmit the information I do know that
where they have direct participation
they are transmitting information to the
equivalent of our Department of
Education that I can say how they
actually accomplish it you know when you
I like to say to people when you've seen
one Medicaid Program you've seen one
Medicaid Program in terms of the
eligibility system that that is used you
know different vendors have different
ways of doing things and even within the
same vendor depending on the state and
the you know the laws and regulations
differently further any other
information yes represent luno so so
thanks very much and and um and I think
this may have come up uh during the I'm
sure this came up during the um during
the hearing but um but potentially
across the state how many students um in
you know ages five to 22 would it be
would it include
22 to age
2222 um could could be eligible to
receive a free and reduced price lunch
if they check the
box so um I know we've provided that
information to the Department of
Education off the top top of my head I
would I didn't sorry I didn't bring that
information with me um but it's it's
calculated um and we've updated a
periodically Department of Education as
the bills have come up right right so so
I wanted to actually use that question
as a way to to introduce just another
concept to consider with that I I
believe the answer is is about 50,000
students would be be eligible is that is
that close well the report says 51,00 79
okay and um and so that under under
current law um in
increases and you're probably looking
right at the report I'm not looking at
it right now would would increase our F
frpl free Inu price lunch uh population
from about 40,000 to about 51 um th000
and um because the state of New
Hampshire also uses the free and reduced
price lunch population as part of the
school funding formula there would be a
corresponding uh increase in uh in
adequacy Grant to uh to school districts
and so that you know approximately
11,000 more students
times uh what are we at
$2,300 um is that the the differentiated
Aid Factor Mr chair something like that
are so so so we'd be we'd be talking
about about $24 million uh per year and
um
though plus extraordinary needs yes and
so so so that would in increase the
grant um to that so I passed around an
amendment and this is actually after um
I uh after talking with some people
about it um and um and you know in light
of a lot of the conversation we had
earlier today on other bills that that
look we're coming into a very tight um
budget year I actually had a
conversation with the governor about
this very thing and um and about this
this very idea and and I said look if we
could make it uh budget neutral uh would
that be something that's interesting and
she goes that's music to my ears and um
and so the amendment that I that I sign
out we're not we're not executing right
now so so so this is just really for
concept so it's Amendment 0
314h um uh ports over some language that
we had in the 2022
23 excuse me you do you have any did the
department get a copy of this you got it
Mark okay thank you okay go ahead yeah
thanks and there's there's there's a
stack of them on the on the uh table
over there as well so so I believe most
I I got them do I think most people but
but um but the this adops language that
the the amendment adops language that we
had in the 22 2022 23 state budget that
used prepandemic uh free and reduced
price lunch enrollments to calculate the
adequacy and the um the I'm not sure we
had the the
um um the extraordinary needs Grant I'm
not sure we had that back then but but
it used it used the prepandemic numbers
uh rather than numbers from the prior
year because the prior year we were on
USDA waivers so there there was very
little paperwork uh completed we didn't
really have accurate counts so so this
this basically does the same thing it
would use it would use uh free
introduced price lunch enrollment from
the present from this current school
year 2024 25 apply that come up with
with a percentage for each um each Town
each school district and each member
town and then would you hold that
percentage for the next two budget years
uh so that they wouldn't be affected by
so so the adequacy grant would would
essentially not be affected by uh by
transition over to Medicaid direct
certification so all all MDC would be
doing is literally feeding more kids
that uh that are qualified for um uh for
free free lunch under the the um USDA
program and it applies to both the
adequacy grant as well as the
extraordinary needs Grant you can see
that on lines um 18 and
amendment are there
further Is there further information to
get from Henry
Litman so he doesn't have to sit there
thank you very much Henry thank you um
appreciate
yeah so this is open to discussion right
now the the this is a work
session
um yes represent spillsbury
so I'd like to direct this question to
representative luno just if I'm
understand understanding what you were
saying you're saying that this
calculation for 2425 school year will
then will be captured and used before
the Medicaid
certification uh enhances the student
count yeah I mean the the intent is for
it to be there um to uh not to be there
before it but to be there as the
Medicaid direct
certification um uh enrolls more
students in free and reduced price lunch
yeah so it would it would keep the the
adequacy calculation essentially in the
the the same way we've been doing so
that you can increase the number
qualifying for free and reduced lunch
without having it Ripple through to the
adequacy formula and the um
extraordinary needs Grant that's correct
to keep it budget neutral but I suppose
then two years after that then those
calculations would C catch up with the
uh increased number correct un unless
then from the depart Department Mark do
there have you calculated by if we got
involved in this program without looking
at that amendment that represent luno
just introduced what would be the total
gain uh cost to that program including
our current amount for f&r which is what
that's around
97 uh yeah 97 million so no yeah in the
extraordinary needs which is 180
something million dollars so um uh the
short answer is we don't know how
without the actual data we don't know
how many students we would pick up um
but doing the fiscal note walks through
a methodology that is you know
reasonable enough um in our our our
estimate is fiscal year 28 and I'll talk
about the timeline of the program but
fiscal year 28 District adequacy ballp
park number would go up by about 50
million so that is the uh uh most uh
significant financial impact is the 50
million increase inadequacy based on
finding around 10,000 is additional
students through Medicaid direct
certification uh the reason why it
impacts fiscal year 28 is because the
timeline of the program so if this bill
were to pass as introduced and as
amended um uh we would enter the program
we would seek application to be in the
program the fall September 25 so this
upcoming fall we would see to get
application then the students would
start direct certifying during school
year um 2627 that's when the
certification would start happening
that's when the program would
essentially be enacted and then 2627
that would impact 2728 District adequacy
so even if you were to pass this speed
speed pass this right now um it would
still only impact District adequacy till
school year 28 uh um fiscal year 28 so
any language you want to uh put here to
uh um you'd want to sync up those school
years to be consistent with how it
impact the funding formula in this
amendment but um yeah essentially the
impact is is $50
million um to District adequacy it also
um hypothetically could uh charter
school and education Freedom account
adequacy but um not at as big a
adequacy how many how many states do you
know that are doing this right now I
know that we got to apply who approves
the application to do this it's a it's a
further any questions of the department
on this from anybody here yes represent
fellows thank you um do you know if um
free and reduced lunch is still being
used in the title one allocation formula
uh it is so um f fnr data is used for a
lot of different allocations um but with
Title One it wouldn't have no uh
positive or negative impact it would
just change how we allocate out the the
lumps some money that comes in so um um
if your town had a lot of students who
were on Medicaid but not if not filling
out the fnr form um under this program
your percentage would go up and
therefore you'd get a higher percentage
of this C1 Grand that's how that would
just follow up and and if you Ju Just to
just so we all understand what's going
on so Title One allocation the amount to
be allocated is a fixed amount so if one
go one District it goes up in some other
District it'll have to go down correct
so no net no net impact but your
allocation would change that's correct
can you just tell us if you know other
ways that it's being used well I'd like
to cut in here just Carl Perkins Carl
Perkins um so when we're talking about
Career Technical education how would
that this impact the Carl Perkins so no
net change to the bottom line from a
Statewide perspective but as represented
fellas was uh discussing it would change
the allocations so if you happened in
your community to have a lot of Medicaid
students um that were not fnr snap tan
if your percentage would go up and if
your percentage went up and your peer
somewhere it's got to fall down so
because it's so the allocations would
change so you'd see a little bit of
Shifting I I can't talk to the speak to
the magnitude but I wouldn't expect a
huge magnitude shift in in allocations
so you're correcting something I always
thought the other way I thought the
number of people we had which were
qualify as poverty impacted the amount
of money given to us by given granted to
us by the feds
um that no okay no the only the only the
only uh uh uh funding component that I'm
aware of and I'm I'm I'd say I'm fairly
confident but I'm 100% confident because
there's so many different aspects of it
but I'm only aware of adequacy where
that would actually go up um actually go
up by count the rest of it's allocations
and if it's allocations it's a lump sum
of money that gets allocated out based
on fnr
percentages ref and Luna so thanks very
much and thanks Mark also I I don't know
if you can on this but I um there may
have been testimony on this during the
the hearing but um but I think the
number of the number of free introduced
price lunch enrollment Statewide could
affect uh another um grant called the
child care
scholarship is there any is that a DHHS
Grant I I I don't know
but yeah I can't speak to that DH just
grant so maybe Laura can speak to that
when yeah we're done with the deal yeah
but but it it's I think it's another
area where where if you see an increase
in um in free and reduced price lunch
enrollment then you then you'll see more
money uh appropriated to the child care
scholarship which will help families you
know in every city and town across the
state in the education space I'm fairly
confident just adequacy would increase
the dollar amount the rest would be
allocations but that's good to point
yeah I I Mark job I would want to
see second written
into
form it
and
whatever
because of numbers so important to to
put it in the adequacy form explain why
some of those why they don't match other
you
know that's a stylistic decision I think
either way functionally works the same
but that's a a
style different style of doing
it any other information we'd like to
time not see any hands flying here Mark
um the Kelly Rambo's here and Melissa
white director white um uh of course
this impacts the nutrition program so
more people ignore students accessing
meals would cause more Federal
reimbursement of meals those meals um so
if you need questions relative to the
nutrition impacts of this program uh
Kelly Rambo is here oh we'd like to hear
to to Mark no to Kelly I'd like to make
some remarks about the nutrition oh okay
okay
okay so anybody else from the Department
is going to help us on the nutrition
it good afternoon Kelly Rambo from the
Department of Education Bureau of
um I can speak to any questions
particular to the um nutrition side for
the Medicaid or hopefully answer your
questions um for the Medicaid direct
program okay are there any
questions represent
D thank you Mr chair um so just for
committee members who may not be aware
I'm a retired dietitian diabetes
educator and my mom was a school lunch
director a long time ago so my questions
come from that background as well as
interest in feeding kids thank you for
being here to help us with
this could you give us some background
about the difference in the nutritional
composition of item served in the school
meal program compared to the same named
item in the retail
Marketplace like a donut versus a donut
or a pancake or whatever could you just
comment on that um sure I can touch upon
upon that um and thank you for the
question the um federal guidelines um do
have specific calorie limits sodium
limits fat limits um and that depends
upon what grade the student might be in
that is eating it it's also dependent
upon um daily averages versus um weekly
averages depending also if you operate a
4-day school week or a 5-day school week
um so there are a lot of things to take
into consideration um that the federal
government has put into place for that
um the the vendors that would produce a
product that is um shelf stable or ready
to go um as as you would call it in um
school um do have to Fe meet those
guidelines um and they do look different
than um what a offthe shelf product
might be as well too that have to meet a
different set of dietary guidelines um
so there are definitely differences um
them further questions can I go a little
more detail on that sure thank you so um
just because this has come up both the
other day when we were hearing the bill
and on similar bills in past years um I
really want to just highlight for folks
how significantly different they are the
new utri s that are most deficient in
children and teens are iron vitamin D
calcium zinc magnesium fiber and
potassium all of which are critically
important to cognitive function and
health and
well-being so one example a same siiz
doughnut
store-bought generally is going to have
white flour no whole grain therefore no
fiber 2 migs of iron iron 120 of calcium
56 of potassium and the school donut is
Hoy flour doesn't seem like it is you
can't recognize it as such in the way
the texture is or or The Taste but it's
Hoy flour which means that whole grain
component goes from zero to just under
18 gram the iron goes from 2 to 10 Mig
the calcium goes up 30 Mig and the
potassium more than doubles so it looks
like it it's understandable that folks
would look at many of the items in the
menus and think well we're not feeding
kids very good food but this is one
example of
many where the food is actually
profoundly more nutritious than what we
perceive it to be um so I think it's
important to be aware of that and in the
handouts that I circulated that the top
page is a menu from the Clarmont Middle
School um from what's two two weeks
front back um the next two pages of that
are the standards the requirements for
the breakfast program and the school
lunch program and you can see um as
Rambo mentioned three different levels
so there's a standard of how much food
of each category for K to 5 6 to 8 and 9
to
12 um and it's broken down in terms of
the requirements for particular amounts
of different kinds of vegetables over
the course of the week um and just
because I always found this sort of
puzzling at first not to get in the
weeds but in the footnotes it talks
about for some items that the minimum
credible serving meaning credible that
you can count it towards the school meal
requirements is an eighth of a cup
that's because a meal might have a bunch
of different items so say you had tacos
and it had lettuce and tomatoes and
onions and
peppers you wouldn't have a half a cup
of each one you'd have an eighth of a
cup of each one to Total the required
amount
um the data on actually I'm going to ask
M rainbow can you speak about the data
on the difference in nutrition between
the school lunch meals and what kids are
eating if they're not having school
lunch I don't know if you have that
available um I
available so in the page that single
page looks like
this um nicely provided to us from
Hunger
Solutions you can see the score scoring
the rightand bar graph um when they
score the nutrition quality of lunches
from home versus school
lunches and this is data over a long
period of time I remember knowing this
when my kids were in their 30s were in
school um lunches from home across the
board are less nutritious than the
school lunch
program partly because the people who
qualify for the free and reduced meals
don't have the resources at home to be
buying the fresh food that is served in
the program so they're generally not
putting fresh fruit an abundant amount
of vegetables they're usually not using
lean protein sources because fatty
protein sources are cheaper and the
sodium content is way way above what the
school lunch sodium content is so I
don't want to hijack the work session
I'm happy to provide background input
now or later for anybody who wants
it can you just fill in whatever else
you would like us to be aware of oh
sorry I don't want it be a oneway street
here questions and maybe trying to go
ahead yeah so so thanks thank you Mr
chair and thanks um as always for for
joining us so if if there's 10 or 11,000
um additional kids that would come into
the program qualifying for let let's say
free lunch just because I think most of
the kids in the program are free lunch
not free not reduce but but just to just
to keep the math simple what does what
does that mean I mean I know you know
there's 180 days of school but not
everybody's in school every day and not
everybody eats the school lunch every
day but but um but um and maybe that's
sort of like rounder what I'm really
trying to get at is is what sort of
funding what sort of increase in USDA
funding would this mean that would help
families pocketbooks reduce their cost
um so that would be and you said for
sorry 10 10,000 is kids you know coming
to school for you know 160 days each or
or eating e you know coming where
they're eating meals may we say 150 days
150 days eating breakfast and lunch um
thank you for the question um
so let's just hypothetically say on an
average um a breakfast might be at the
local level for a paid um paid meal um
between a do to let's say $2 because
that is also figured out at the local
level so that could be um the cost
savings for a family um just for
breakfast and then for lunch it can
range from um 225 to uh let's just say
$4 um so that could be a cost savings
per lunch per student so um with that
average let's say if they did get
breakfast and lunch it could be2 to
maybe $8 um you know per per day um and
those are just rough um five bucks would
be sort of a good a good happy medium
there times 10,000 kids so so $50,000 a
day in in in relief to families across
the state times potentially times you
know how many every day you know 150 to
180 days potentially yes great
thanks thanks Mark thanks Mark
yeah are there any additional costs to
the local districts if we went with this
program for serving this food preparing
this
food um there's always the the potential
um for that there there could be an
increased cost um beneficially um for
those students that possibly didn't get
breakfast before and now they do qualify
for breakfast um maybe they chose not to
participate for because they couldn't
afford it but now if they they are
qualified on this program there could be
additional meals um that that would need
to be made at the local level so there
is the potential for um an additional
cost at the local level I noticed in the
the fiscal note there are additional
costs for the Department of Education
and administering this
program so I'm I was just curious to
know on the local level whether this is
going to C cost more in terms of those
preparing it or administering or the
added dollars in a large District like a
Manchester um is this going to be more
administrative cost for
them there is the the potential um you
know for for that as as well too I think
with any increase program there there
does come some um some costs that um
again would be beneficial to to the
students um in that case but there's
always that possibility of potential um
costs and um as previously stated if a a
district or a school does not offer
breakfast um let's just say and we um
operate this program and they'd like to
start a breakfast program that could
also be a potential cost because they do
see that there's more students that
qualify um so they would like to bring a
breakfast program in there that they
possibly didn't have before so Mr chair
yes yeah just while while we're on this
um talking about cost to the district
let's also talk about the other side of
the the you know the the profit line on
this so we talked about uh School
breakfast and lunch cost and I think we
even said I think I use the word happy
medium was five bucks if you did both
you know a buck for breakfast four bucks
for lunch I think you there's certainly
a range but but that was it um happy
happy medium there is is what that's
what the school would normally charge
that's full price full price um for for
a free breakfast and a free lunch for
both meals total could be five bucks
Buck for the breakfast four bucks for
lunch but you you looking at the
information from Hunger Solutions the
school would get actually get reimbursed
$237 for a breakfast it charges full
price
for for a dollar they're going to get $2
$
37 and for a lunch that they charge four
bucks for a full price they get
$443 so in that case it's 680 isn't that
a $180 profit for the um so I can't
speak to the document that you have in
front of you um I think that Miss milin
would be able to speak to that but um if
I understand the the question or um the
statement um
that that reimbursement is for a free
meal so um the school would not be
charging the student for um for that
price and they would get that
reimbursement only for um the free meal
and they get it at a higher rate than
their than their full price that's
correct and there's um a different
reimbursement for um the full price meal
if they were to um to charge that to a a
student Oh you mean the reduce price whe
um so there's there yep free reduced and
paid so there's different reimbursement
rates depending upon what meal was
served right right thank
you while you're in front of us we have
another bill here it's also dealing with
application when I talked with my
district they're saying they already
have an online application in
place uh is this occurring elsewhere
within the state um thank you for the
question
so um previously during the the first
hearing for this we did um testify that
we don't have that that data at the
department there are um school districts
and schools that do have online
applications already in in place um but
we don't currently have the data on
exactly which ones um do we did put out
a voluntary survey um after um also um
speaking to the meal debt um we
proactively put the application um
question in there along with the the
meal debt survey as well too um and they
um they meaning the the districts have
until the 14th to reply to that um and
once that was done I was going to
provide that to to you so you have that
information um just to currently right
now um again remember that it is
voluntary um and right now we have about
44 responses um to to the um to the
survey so um that's a good data to start
with um but obviously we um you know
we're relying upon um the voluntary
nature of that so 44 out of how many um
thereabouts representa papait very
briefly um having being a uh Finance
director I remember that I wasn't
exactly that Keen on feeling survey is
way before the deadline so I wouldn't
trade too much into the 44 just a quick
question if I may um would you think
that uh districts which are concerned
about their school Mill debt you know
the unpaid balance would be rather
likely to jump on the opportunity to
fill the survey and tell you all about
it um I I don't want to speak for the
the districts filling out the survey um
but we did mention that it was
voluntary um and um you know we we did
get some questions on Where where would
this data be um you know be posted or or
um and so um that could potentially um
you know hinder some from um filling out
the survey again um we made it very
clear that it was voluntary um so if I
make quick followup
yes I'm not sure that I understand why a
school district would be concerned about
sharing their you know balance of you
know school debt because that's part of
their financial statements anyway right
is there any privacy what what were the
concerns that they may have expressed to
lead you to think they may be unwilling
to submit it um the the question was
just
um where would this data be um what is
the um request for for the the survey
representative Damon thank
you would it be correct that if Medicaid
direct certification for f&r meals was
in place there would be less
administrative costs to districts than
the method currently in place for f&r
applications um thank you for the
question the Medicaid direct currently
um um in New Hampshire does not qualify
students for meals um so it would open
up a different um subset of students
that would qualify um and the capability
of them to be qualified in what we call
the direct certification process would
eliminate the need for um the additional
application to be filled out so it would
be more efficient and also reduce the
errors in applications yes
um there's a potential for that to to
reduce that um burden on filling out an
additional piece of of um application
for a family to
qualify I have another question but it's
not related to that go ahead thank you
could you inform the committee about the
community eligibility provision for
School meals and what the impact of
Medicaid direct certification might be
on that program
sure um so the community eligibility
program or also known as c um does use
your directly certified um The
District's directly certified data um to
qualify for that percentage right now
currently they use the data that's in
place snap tan if migrant homeless um
and this would also um if Medicaid
direct were to be able to be added into
that um could potentially increase the
um percentage that does qualify for that
um the
other side of the um the community
eligibility program is that um meals
would be provided at no cost to the
student however um the other portion of
let's just say a district has
25% or let's say 40% um then 60% would
need to be covered by the local level or
non federal funds um so that's important
information to to have as well to um to
operate that program so even though um
the ISP um or your directly certified
numbers um maybe were you know lower and
that does qualify you um the local level
does need to come up with a difference
for what is not paid for at the federal
level if they were in the C correct if
they were to operate the community
eligibility
program further information needed repon
luno yeah thanks um was did the
committee receive the um the I I guess
it I don't know if you call it the
Census Data but basically the comparison
by town of of the number of students in
the 2026 free and reduced price
lunch admr compared to the by town the
number of students that are that
students that are Medicaid enrolled and
would would qualify under Medicaid
direct um
certification so so back I think a
couple of years ago Mark when when when
we were when um representative lad and I
were were working with you and
representative umberger there was a
comparison spreadsheet that that you did
and I just pulled it up and and I just
picking on on a couple of a couple of
towns like let's pick on Al cuz middle
um so the the the the the
2026 fnr count estimate is 202 whereas
the Medicaid direct certification would
be
244 and this is from the spreed you did
in Hopkinson the
um frpl um is 78 Medicaid direct it's
118 in hener so I'm just picking on hes
here it goes from 99 to
153 and um and so just wondering if if
if the members of this committee would
like to see what what these how the
enrollment compare oh the Medicaid
direct certification would compare to
current free and reduced price lunch
enrollment so we could see so we could
each see what it means to our you know
constituents but also but also Statewide
and you know it's important to look at
places like Manchester and Nashua um too
and
um Manchester goes from
5,857 in the in the
2026 free introduce price lunch to
6,974 in the um Medicaid direct I would
be comfortable of sharing that data so
essentially um uh dhj does um when they
gave us the data for us to do the
analysis to basically identify those 10
approximate 10,000 students they did
have it at the Town level um for
whatever reason Penacook is always kind
of unique they didn't have Penacook so
an assumption was made about you know
percentage of students that could be
Penacook out of conquered so um some
assumptions were made in that data set
um but essentially dhjs did provide us
that data set um and we have a
comparison to current law to what
Medicaid direct might might be and it's
it estimates um U you know approximately
10,000 students
um there are some peculiarities with the
data in a sense that sometimes when we
looked at what DHHS had for Medicaid
students uh children uh ages 5 through
18 um um sometimes the medic number was
lower than what the fnr number was so
that was interesting that was just
students not on Medicaid but on fnr Snap
or tanif so that did happen in a few
instances that was less common it's more
common that you the Medicaid number has
the larger data set um but we can
provide that data yeah so Mark when we
looked at that data years ago we saw
that following 8th
grade there is a drop and Kelly I think
you may have seen this before too A Drop
in participants in the f&r
program uh due to high school students
either not wanting to you know identify
as fnr or or going with their buddies
somewhere and having a meal somewhere
else it's more to their liking um are in
projecting the figures right here are we
taking in account that waterfall effect
that we see from middle school into high
school we just we took um the raw data
that Medicaid provided to us by town and
we we did no analysis no analysis by
cohort level or anything just raw data
by town and compared it
okay did you but just a follow up on
your question Rick I'm sorry to
jump represent Mr chair I'm sorry um but
but did did we did we see a
corresponding drop off during during
waivers did um uh yeah yes once when the
USDA um when USDA did not require the
form and you could access meals without
a form um substantial drop off um no
that's that's that's not what I meant
did did did
kids did did the did the did the number
of meals go the other way consumed under
under waivers go up yeah yeah I mean
they they were okay eating the meals
and more participation yeah um yes there
was an increase in participation um with
the the waivers and not having um the
forms to to fill out okay great that was
at the high school
level um the elementary I can see it yes
I would say AC that was across the board
um that there was an increase in meals
when they were served at no
cost gon
Damon could either of you clarify come
up earlier thank you could either of you
clarify this came up earlier this
afternoon and um Mark you just mentioned
18 so does the fnr program end at 18
years old or does it go for kids who are
still in school up to
22 yeah I I don't recall if the data set
we used is through 18 the data set we
used to do the analysis might have been
through 18 but if you're in school and
you're 21 um I'm not aware of any restri
that would we would count you You' be
part of adequacy um so I don't think
there's any limitation there like to
clarify that thank you okay we do have
several other bills uh you don't have to
get up yet um dealing with uh meals we
have one relative the eligibility for
free School meals that's increasing the
eligibility level and the other one 703
relative prohibiting school districts
from denying meals to students with
unpaid meal balances and this is the one
I want to talk about
you did you're doing a survey on that
you don't have that information back on
what these balances are at the end of
the year and how much total we are bless
in the state because of that I do have
um preliminary data that I could provide
um digitally to to the committee um but
we gave until the 14th to submit that
full data set
okay okay is there any other information
here we want to get from doe it's time
for us maybe to have a little discussion
amongst ourselves here as to you
know where we're going with these
bills thank you very
much
um I I think I I'm hearing the big issue
is the additional
cost am I wrong on that $50
million for what for what for which
which one Medicaid direct well we've got
an amendment that takes that addresses
that the 50 mon for the first several
years yeah for the first in this budget
yeah yeah yeah but but also we've got
school funding to I mean there's a lot
there's a lot of things that I think are
going to overtake I know I know
it is there any other discussion on
this Mr chair do you mean on the
Medicaid director or on all on all of
them um so if I could I'd like to bring
up the amendment to
703 yeah you have one I circulated it
you should have it um so there is sorry
copy thank you um for 703 yeah which is
the one in regards to prohibiting
districts from shaming students who have
meal debt um amendment number 034 43
which you should have in front of you
removes the part of the bill that would
have required doe to pay off school
district's meal debt so it leaves the
exact same
language of the first part of the bill
detailing the specifics of not shaming
students in regard to their debt um and
leaving
in uh let me see what number it is here
page two line five requiring school
districts to accept voluntary donations
to alleviate School Meal debt because
there were issues with that in the last
school
year um so if the amendment is approved
there is no cost to this bill it is
simply a policy statement to districts
about kindness and respect to students
who are not responsible for their status
in
poverty yes
thank
you can you share with me how are school
districts shaming these kids I mean what
what's happening out there thank you for
question there are a number of ways that
a child would be identified as being a
person in debt or with limited
resources it could be that the school
district gives them different food maybe
a cold sandwich instead of the selection
from a menu like what I
circulated that is legal to do it's not
very
kind um and it makes kids not go get the
meal because they're stigmatized by
being that
child um they could have to have a rband
or some other
identifier um that Flags them as the
person who has debt there have been a
number of instances of a cashier saying
to a child you don't have enough money
on your account for that you can't have
that and making them put food back which
then that food actually can't be serve
to anybody else either because it's been
handled by a consumer so that's the
ultimate
waste
um I don't know if there are currently
any districts in New Hampshire that what
I'm about to say has occurred but I know
that
in history and in the National Data kids
have been prohibitive from participating
in field trips or activities there's
just a whole list of ways that we shame
the poor so this is just intended to be
a statement to say we are not the state
that does that we are a state that is
kind and respectful to our
status
thank you Mr chair um in looking on the
bill I appreciate the amendment to it
because that was definitely a big
concern the removed language I'm still
looking at um
FG and
H um and if you wouldn't mind maybe you
know going through them my concern with
f is
that there is a huge difference between
somebody who cannot pay for their School
meals and somebody who won't pay for
their School meals and if we tell the
schools you just cannot collect at all
for lunch why would any well that's how
I read F I mean I would appreciate then
an understanding of what am I miss
reading
here yeah thank you for the
question so it's saying that the school
district can't use a collections agency
to collect unpaid School Mills debt it's
not saying that the district can't make
the responsible parties parents
Guardians aware of the debt we're not
asking them to not request payment we're
not sending it to collection however
that's F if I may yes and would it be
appropriate to maybe go back and forth a
little in this case thank you I I just
want to be careful Mr chair so problem
is I understand that I can send send the
bill right but what is the school
district supposed to do if they send the
bill to the richest house in town and
they just don't pay that isn't happening
under this under this it may create
basically if you are telling me that I
can send you a bill but I cannot use a
collection agency or any other legal
means to collect a
debt you are basically telling that
person who may have paid before that hey
there is no consequence to not paying
for my launch just going to take the
free ride because the school district
will have to eat it I'm I'm looking at
moral hazards right I'm not saying
that's a current issue because under the
current scenario we obviously have a way
to collect and I agree with it at
sometimes school in May but my my
opinion crossed the line and became
overly aggressive so I think there is
something that we could look at that
there but this seems to go all the way
the other way to you cannot collect even
from people who absolutely have the
means I just don't feel like it again we
don't have to have a definitive answer
but I want you to understand what my
concerns are and see if you have any
thoughts on
concerns I would just respond to that
part and then move on to three
um I think people can come from
different perspectives
on what our responsibil ility is to poor
people and I
would substantially weigh the
value of
this to the poor students who would be
shamed for
debt and eliminating that
shaming I think the value of that is far
far greater than whatever minimal risk
there may be of the random
rare take advantage
person I mean frankly if you're that
well to do
you know the kids are probably going out
to
lunch um I just don't see that as a
primary variable on the GS side um G is
the require schools to develop an
outreach program to ensure to encourage
parents or Guardians to apply for the
free Price my question was why a mandate
it seems that the schools already have
an incentive to do so and as far as I
know they tend to be very good about
reminding people and they're already
doing everything they can my question is
why why then do we need to codify a
requirement here which can lead us down
the path of unfunded mandates and all
that I think the intent of that Clause
is to make sure that we reach out to
every child or every family who would
benefit from free and reduced meals so
that we are decreasing the incidence of
childhood hunger but
similarly H H is actually already in
federal statute it's just including in
our statute because it's so related to
this that schools are allowed to
facilitate completing the
application following the federal
code understood if I may come back to G
last are you aware of any schools that
don't try hard enough so that we need to
codify this into the law I don't need
names for the schools but are you aware
of schools that just don't do it even
though the adequacy funding and
everything depends on
it I don't have a Statewide survey of
what all the schools are doing I know
what schools in my district do so I
don't think I'd be able to answer that
broadly thank you okay are there yes
represent cocom thank you Mr chair going
back to f um you know I agree that there
are kids out there and families out
there that that are definitely poor and
they're struggling and they need help
absolutely agree with that and I don't
think it's fair that the kids should be
faced with these dilemmas at school when
it comes to their parents who are making
bad financial decisions that are putting
them in this position um but when it
goes to the collection agency I don't I
struggle with that one because there are
parents out there that do have the means
but they're making decisions with their
money that is may not be prioritizing
their kids eating uh their their uh
lunch program you know they've got cell
phones they've got cigarettes they've
got fancy cars they've got all these
other things but their kids still going
to school hungry and that's not the
kids's fault but I don't think we should
be eliminating that responsibility from
those parents who are making poor
decisions and not prioritizing their
kids meals ahead of time ahead of other
things things so I really think we need
to be keeping that in
there yes thank you Mr chairman I I
appreciate the compassion and and
everything that you're saying I want to
put you into my classroom for just a
couple of seconds on the period before
lunch and the child came into my
classroom and ate his lunch and then he
goes to the lunchroom and he fills up
his tray and this prohibits the
lunchroom from any recourse to stopping
him from taking a second
lunch if if they're prohibited from
denying a meal and prohibited from
disposing or taking away and they're
prohibited from identifying or
stigmatizing and they go down the
theft let me clarify if I may the
circumstance you're
describing so your
student had a lunch available to them he
brings his lunch into the classroom
brought lunch with him is that what
us
I what I want to say is presumably that
child was hungry enough to need both
lunches like maybe they didn't have
breakfast maybe they don't have
dinner and how common is that I mean
honestly
people I don't have a further
respon okay I yes representative
Brown so a related bill here is
665 which raises
the minimum to 300% of the federal
poverty guidelines for eligibility for
free School
meals
um and that's in this the same batch of
bills
I'm just concerned because the fiscal
note states that this has a this has a
significant fiscal impact potentially
since 300% of the federal poverty rate
includes 50% of the student
population and could increase a cost to
the state of $48 million per year so I'm
wondering while 300% or lower of the
poverty rate group is benef benefited
what happens to the
31% and to
375% um of the federal poverty rate
families they'll
be ask asking to be uh burdened with
additional taxes
so and you see what I'm saying here um
I'm
665 because many families are struggling
even at
350% of the federal poverty
rate yeah yeah no sure sure I'll take it
so so this is a lot of the same argument
we hear on vouchers too and that that
you need to you got to there there's
somebody that's at 351 per of poverty so
we've got to increase vouchers to 400%
got to increase it to 500% there's
somebody that makes um
$179,000 a year which is $100 more than
the 500% cut off so we need to increase
it to unlimited so that somebody making
um
$500,000 a year can get a free voucher
from State of New Hampshire taxpayers
what we're talking about here is feeding
hungry
kids and right now we feed hungry kids
for free who fill out the paperwork up
to13 % of the poverty line 131 you fall
into the reduced plan 185 you're still
in reduced my my understanding there's
not a whole bunch that fall into the
reduced most of it is in the is in the
is in the full um free category so I
don't know what happens when you get to
186% or 300% or 30% but we're not asking
taxpayers to Pony up a $7,000 freaking
School voucher to pay for School tuition
we're talking about feeding hungry kids
here so shame on just the question Mr
chair point of order yeah I'm done could
we keep the language under control I
mean be careful FWS are I didn't drop
okay I yeah we yeah we won't do that
anymore um okay so we have it's at 2:15
right now and uh we're at the end of the
time for the first discussion on on
meals and now we're going to jump into
and we're going to take a f minute break
here for everybody take a break and walk
a little bit then we're going to come
back and start with the issues on
special education we're taking five yep
yep yep wake
up these days are all sorry about the
word freaking yeah but it's a good it's
yeah
e
go ahead and get going here on the next
topic and the next topic is one which
deals with the costs of special
education
services and also the area of special
education Aid which is the old
catastrophic Aid
uh this is a a pretty complex uh topic
right here Mark or Brian are you going
to be able to discuss with us and should
you come up to the table right now
before we ask you to come on up because
In-N-Out now we've had a sheet here just
presented to
us this was put together by Department
of
Education
um could Brian could you explain this
one to us or or Mark
already have the sheet that I'm looking
around yes uh thank you for the question
my name is Brian e and Department of
Education Bure School Finance Mark Mello
Bureau School Finance so this in
particular is looking at um five
district for FY 24 the revenue versus
expenditures and revenue being three
categories that we have there those are
those first three columns after District
name so that would be sped Aid Revenue
state aid that's a special education Aid
catastrophic Aid next column would be
differential Aid that would be uh the
aid through the adequacy formula that
would be specifically for um
the you went a little quickly I'm sorry
Brian slow down it's the end of the
day sure so um it would be 1 2 3 4 5 the
fifth column is differential Aid Revenue
parenthesis
State sped Aid Revenue differential Aid
correct idea correct and sped total sped
correct so those Revenue columns would
be the revenue for each district so
special education Aid and then
specifically special education um
adequacy Aid and then idea through the
federal government so it's a mix of
state revenue for specifically for
special education and then Federal um
Revenue specifically for Education uh
special education and then that last
total sped expenditures that's what's
reported through the doe 25s annually um
as reported by the districts to the
department so then uh the following
columns would be the percent that is
covering those expenditures so the first
one being percent State covering
expenditures so that's that's basically
the expenditures for each district
divided by the state um Revenue so and
then that would be the two columns sped
Aid Revenue special education Aid and
differential Aid
revenue and then the same goes for the
federal government that would be the
total special education expenditures
divided by just the federal revenue and
then uh another column being state and
federal revenue covering expenditures so
that would be Aid coming into the
district from the state and the federal
government for Revenue covering those
expenditures and the final column being
percent District covering expenditures
so basically it's the remainder percent
that would be covered um by local
Revenue local taxation uh for each
district and then at the top um my mine
is color code I'm not sure if yours is
but the uh top one you'll see Statewide
totals that's just a sum of each one of
those revenues and expenditures and then
to the right is medians so that's just
the median for each one of those um
percent um covering expenditures for
okay yes thank you thank you Mr chairman
so my eye is drawn to my town Epsom on
the first page here and what I don't
understand is um it says that uh 3% is
federal 9% is state but Federal is
149,000 and state is
242,000
so one's not three times the other
number this thank you for the question
the state would cover that would be both
special education Aid Revenue that first
Revenue column as well as differential
Aid the second column so it's a sum of
those two first columns are Revenue so
State being special education Aid as
well as State uh special education
adequacy I see so it's more like 400
total that sounds correct yes uh yes yep
much when you're looking at the special
education Aid on that First
Column that 34
million for the state
33.9 you have all those numbers down
below have you broken it down any
farther as far as um how expens like the
number of of
students uh for each like for
example um ammer just it's right at the
$196,000 how many students does that
involved my guess would be two but or
maybe two two or three but we don't have
this as part of this chart we provided
it through other uh examples before but
we haven't put that into this handout
necessarily
sometimes we have limitations when we
try to do per student calculations
because we have to have the granularity
to match the cost with the student we
have some ability to do that but for
example if you're using admr that would
include all the students you're tuition
out um and the students you might
educate educate inous um but your cost
might associate spe special education
students coming into your District so
they can get a little um uh a little
more Technical and into the weeds and if
you're going to match the student with
the cost sometimes it just requires um
drilling down and it can get a little
more
challenging
yes sorry thank
you in the final column percent District
covering expenses that the uh Statewide
I guess average is
85% there's a very small number of
districts I said percent State covering
I mean % District covering there's a
very small number of
towns
that the district coverage is much lower
percentage like right on top of Albany
at
28% further down the page Colombia at 5%
there's a couple others in the
20s how do they get to be such a low
percent of the district paying the costs
thank you for the question uh off top of
my head those two districts you
mentioned I believe are non-operating
districts those are districts that don't
operate their own schools so that
students would attend out of District
potentially so that that might be the
case as well uh for that
example so that when so how does that
doesn't the sending town still have to
pay when the district reports the
expenditures total special special
education expenditures on d25 that would
be educating students in their own
District so those costs would be
included in tuition wouldn't necessarily
um as as instructed on the du2 wouldn't
be a cost Associated for expenditure of
special education those would be
attributed to tuition
potentially I clarify that
yes so Goan is one example of what I
just asked about and it's in my district
and so they're listed at 22% for the
district covering the expenses and they
are what you just described they have no
school in town they tuition their
students to other
communities so I'm just trying to
understand where does it if there is a
student needing special education
services from Goan let's say being
educated in Newport down the road so are
their expenses showing up in the Newport
data uh both places actually but well it
could be both places so there's double
counting in here when you try to sum up
and look at it but each Goan would need
to report um expenditures tuition and
and Newport would need to uh produce
expenditures as far as teacher a teacher
they hired so it would show up twice one
of the challenges is not every district
has a I don't know what H Go's agreement
is but sometimes they don't have
separate tuition agreements that cover
special education costs so sometimes
they have a one a one price tuition
agreement so they they say Newport will
accept your students and this will be
the cost per student sometimes they
carve it out and say a non-sp special
education student shall be this cost
special education student shall be of
this cost so when Goan pays that tuition
bill they might not actually parse out
from an accounting perspective on the
doe2 those exacts cost and when Newport
receives that student and this is a
hypothetical I don't know their tuition
agreement they might not hypothetically
parse out that revenue is being special
education Revenue so there are
limitations to the doe2 based on the
limitations of the accounting that
school districts do to actually account
for um specifically special education
costs so there's limitation and we see
that in the doe2 as you drill day thank
you yes represent papovich thank you Mr
CH just to follow up on what you were
just saying I understand that you cannot
report the data you have and if you
don't have that data you cannot report
it at a you know more accurate level but
would you feel that in this summary with
the exception of a couple of small
districts would this have any material
impact on this spreadsheet because the
numbers look to be tiny the ones that
are duplicated but I don't want to just
assume I would appreciate your thought
in terms of what order of magnitude
there or maybe maybe we looking at
understanding cannot be corrected but
what do I need to adjust for do you know
County um yeah I think the number the
double counting so we do ask districts
to to report what data they do have we
do ask them to report us uh to us what
special education costs were paid to
another New Hampshire school district
and that number usually hovers around 12
million a year so that Topline number um
has about $12 million in double counting
so on the grand scale of things not not
super
material no I I I understand why schools
are screaming and yelling about this
when I look at this really portrays it
well on the right hand side looks like
I'm I'm just going down here 85% of
these costs are paid by the
local 5% by the feds and the FEDS got us
in this business saying they're going to
pay 40%
here we are we consistently see these
numbers yeah that but I I have a
question and Terry just brought it up to
me and I I have this I'm looking at my
town of
havil and we have no special education
Aid yet we have our own school which
we're providing some of that support
don't we get funded for that
support uh uh special education aid
meaning uh um have somebody up and down
and up and down over here so so no uh um
uh if if you have student coming from
Benton to hail yeah um and that student
is a high cost bed student being
educated by hav roll now typically those
high cost students are not going to holl
they're going to an out of District
placement um but uh in that scenario if
hail was educating a high cost special
education student um the money the
revenue would show up in Benton if the
student lived in Benton um or some some
neighbor in town I I get that and know
because we have a number of towns but
Hao itself does have kids but we we're
sending them to a separate School while
we're doing it
ourselves I I I I have to ask the local
people about oh so hail does have high
cost special education students we have
King Street
school it's a separate School within the
public school
system okay and I'll to ask them this is
not part of today's discussion this
another
deal um
fellows just tell us which numbers
you're using are you using adma or
admr
and and the special ed that's one
question and the other one is the
special ed Aid which is formally called
catastrophic um is that going
to um it probably goes to whomever pays
the bill which could be the District of
residents or it could be the um
receiving districts that is not our
program but it goes to the district of
responsibility so District of residents
Works um and I don't know if there's any
ADM on this data
set I think it
could Poss well I don't know I know it
gets up kind of high but it could be
going to it so the money could go to the
district of residence because in case of
Pinkerton and in Dairy maybe the actual
expenditures are well we can't even see
the expenditures of Pinkerton this is a
little inside baseball they're they're
doing a SD level they're doing a SD
level uh uh uh they have the SD of the
date of the high cost student so we know
it's a district of Resident student okay
now these costs which I'm seeing the
First Column are 33. $34 million you
can't really that's what you projector
or is that what you
prated that's the final pration amount
that's the pration amount so the actual
amount is 501 for
expenditures well that would be claim
the um submitted claims the entit yeah
the entitled again this is not our Pro
yes um $33 million almost $34 million
would be the amount that was actually
paid through special education Aid to
so yes go ahead so the the difference
there between the the 51 and the and the
33 that would be picked up in the total
column yeah that number would live there
you
yes thank you um sorry I'm a little
confused so if you guys have already
answered this it didn't stick so I
apologize for that um so looking at a
couple of towns Windsor and um Rivendell
at the end so why would they have
differential aid but no other Aid can
you help clear that up in my head
please sure thank you for the question I
suspect that that's are very small those
are very small districts where there
might be students that are special
education uh that are eligible for
special education but they aren't in the
special education aid program so they're
relatively a lowcost special education
student um so it might only be for
example Windsor um that looks to be
about three or four students uh or two
students for that are eligible for
differential aid for adequacy special
education adequacy but they just aren't
right they're just not a potentially
high cost student that would be eligible
for the uh CAD a program special educate
and rivale is an interstate School
couple couple things rivendale we don't
get fin natureal reports on them Vermont
uh Vermont in between in between uh
halfway some districts particularly
small districts don't take advantage of
ID a so w that might be a situation
Windsor might have an allocation but
they might not I I don't know for a fact
you'd have to get special education
Bureau staff in here but um I think you
answer it well another thing to point
out um this data set Special Education
data the cost is from the previous year
the revenue comes in the next year so
there's a one-year lag on this data um
so you could see some mix matching from
from from that as well follow on yes so
where you were talking about there were
some duplications in numbers Windsor
tuitions into Hillsboro Dearing so would
Hillsboro Dearing also be showing that
8,000 on their report that' be duplicate
cost if it's reported if it's a report
on the doe2 it' be duplicated so is the
do25 just a state form or is that
federal state form thank you represent
May Mayhem thank you for taking my
question thank you for this stuff of
nightmare I just have a couple of things
it it looks like Stark when the
motherload was 71% state and federal aid
but then the the 55% at Unity strikes me
as a message to Congress are you telling
155% so that could be um um a student
the cost what that could be a situation
where the cost for the high cost SP uh
special education student was uh um they
received the revenue it could be a
mismatch between when the revenue came
in and when the costs were incurred so
if they had uh the cost in the previous
year so if they had the cost in fiscal
year 23 they would have been they would
have paid that cost in 23 and then they
would have received Revenue in 24 but
let's say that student graduated so that
could be a situation like that where a
bunch of a bunch of the one you're lag
in revenue is making it look really like
they're profiting essentially um uh but
that's that's probably what that could
be What's Happening
Here Mr chair if I may yes go ahead so
this comes back to what I was going to
ask right because you are reporting here
the 24 Aid and expenditures but just to
summarize that I understand correctly
the 248 is calculated based on the 23
expenditures so for most large districts
this wouldn't be meaningful because you
figure same kid number of kids get in
and out of the program for really small
districts where there are two students
if a new one comes in suddenly they are
going to look horribly underfunded
because they're getting revenues based
on two students but they really have
three now or the other side where they
have two students the previous year they
get the revenue for the two students but
now one student is no longer there so
they appear to get even more than they
are spending so this is what you know
we're looking at because there is a data
you know data is really from two
separate
years there may be some timing issues
that we need to be careful for yeah we
we've been doing this report for a few
years now because it it's a a frequently
Asked report um but we probably need to
consider maybe syncing up the years with
the data set so it would be a nice
choice you know because I mean if you
already have the data looking at it
longitudinal it wouldn't be that big of
a deal and you can see anyway thank you
y I've got a question on differentiated
Aid um that seems to be a huge category
here uh
of oh what 90 or how much money are
right here
68.7 estimated and going forward for FY
26 um is there any way we could find
out what are the case loads of various
special education teachers in the
building what's the average case load
for a speech pathologist a physical
therapist a old resource room teacher uh
older you know where that's used to be
they all went to the resource room or
any of the 13 categorical areas what are
the casee loads
and then we could figure out okay what
is the average cost of a teacher it's
sort of like we do with a formula for uh
base cost for a teacher for a principal
Etc we have uh so many kids for uh 25
to1 30 to1 what is the ratio of case
load to the special education teacher so
I don't think we'd get granular as far
as each individual teacher and their
individual case load um but probably
what we could do is um we have a I
believe we have a survey of all special
education teachers submitted to the
state so we could take a tally of all
special education teachers within a
district and then we could take a tally
of all divided by all special education
students in the district and that would
get you essentially an average case load
uh per teacher but it wouldn't get you
um wouldn't get you too granular but it
would get you a district average where
I'm trying to go Mark is that I've been
in school districts where I've seen a
child who needed little articulation
didn't know to say R whatever a tongue
thrust or whatever and and in one
District that child got two days per
week the same type issue another
District may get five times a
week so the way it's being administered
in the buildings is based upon maybe
Staffing or maybe the individual people
at the IEP meeting a lot of variables
but it's putting our C it's hard to find
out what is the cost of a speech teacher
seeing that it's the local decision is
one which is contributing to what the
costs are we the the analysis you're
describing actually getting into the
cost of a speed pathology teacher yeah
um we can't do that analysis because
that's not on the doe2 um we'd have all
special education employment costs um
I'm just well unless the special
education Bureau I which I don't believe
they have uh uh maybe Ida has some data
but um I can't provide that analysis on
the
doe2 I know you be next Kei represent
her why you just a very simple question
on the on the very last page the
historical Trends
page it the top bar says to the left of
it attributed to the number of students
and then below that attributed to the
average cost per student could you just
explain what the what's going on there
what the differential what the
difference is sorry which document are
you is it oh I look at the long of the
same hand up oh that's didn't you guys
yeah and by the way be nice you could
have sent me the
spreadsheets he always wants it in
digital format but that's not what I'm
asking I'm just asking about it's
actually you wanted me to show give you
this yeah I apologize we don't have that
out Jennifer got it for
us and
okay
yeah must been pretty okay sorry now
that we have it uh would you be able to
repeat your question pardon me just
weren't sure which what the question was
we're looking at it now though the
question is over to the left there the
two top big bars if you will one says
attributed to number of students and
this is talking about basically the
breakdown of cat Aid ratios or brackets
and the next the one below it says
attributed to average cost per student
just trying to understand what thank you
what that's talking about yes this was a
the goal was to look at each year this
is specifically for special education
Aid each year the cost difference and
which what the cost increase year toye
or cost decrease would be attributed to
average cost per student or the amount
of students so it's essentially in a way
cost accounting so for example for FY 24
the top one attributed to number of
students has a $13 million figure while
the bottom uh below one has for the
attributed to average cost per student
is about 10 million that's essentially
taking and if I misspeak I apologize I
haven't looked at I haven't looked the
formulas in a while but it would be
basically looking at the amount of
students in FY 24 multiply that by the
average cost of the previous year and
then the reverse or the inverse so
looking at the average cost of this year
FY 24 and then multiplying that by the
amount of students in the previous year
so where there is
a uh I apologize it's about uh it would
be the the the sum of 13 Mill the 13
million figure and the 10 million figure
that would be the split of which would
be the cost that's attribut to the
amount of students verus the average
cost per student thank you follow yes so
did you produce these or did the
department to produce all these
spreadsheets I did yes yeah I did this
one particular would you send them to me
have a chance later on sure yes thank
you with the
okay go ahead rebury so am I reading
this correctly take
2017 if you add the 5 thou 5,6 21 that's
attributed to student count plus the
2,22 th000 which is attributed to um
7,643 is the difference the inflation
Factor basically between the 75 million
for
2017 and the 82 million 600,000 for
2018 is that correct it would be the the
two figures would be the increase from
fy7 from fy16 to 17 so the current year
total sped amount of 82 million seems if
I'm just I'm looking at it it looks to
me like the two subfigures there the two
subtotals under
17 make up the increase to
18 and the two subfigures in 18 make up
certain yes right so you're you're
um the difference
between whether costs are increasing
because of student count versus cost per
student
correct
yes um
so on the on the last
page where you've got um Statewide
student enrollment it's the second to
the last um
169,170 number here is 169 131 but the
2004 number you use in the adequacy um
um estimate for FY 26 is estimated 2425
membership so
that's I I I guess um you know based
thank you I suspect it would be the
combination of so the second number you
mentioned would be for adequa estimating
adequacy and so that would exclude
Charter students it would exclude parent
paid education Freedom account it was
also exclude preschool and postgraduate
um off top of my head that probably
doesn't amount to 15,000 maybe I'm not
too sure um I suppose yeah 5,000 charter
school students 5,000 EFA students so it
could be getting that could be what it's
yeah I mean because it's it's it's about
18,000
off 177,000 off and additionally also
that would be the enrollment versus ADM
r that we calculated through the uh
estimate as well so the enrollment would
be higher um mostly higher as well yeah
so adequacy excludes prek and excludes
um out of state
students all right so this
includes this prek and well this doesn't
says New Hampshire residents oh okay
never mind then and it says submissions
by
districts so so Does it include um
Charters we'll have to dig into the data
okay thank it it's it's a question that
yes
students is that percent of students
with
IEPs a percentage of the whole of all
the kids in our state or what is it when
what it has to be like the 151,000 kids
have which page are you I'm on the last
page Final Call final call T typically
around 20 20% of students have IEPs um
this particular metric we might need to
dig into the data exactly what's the we
well the numerator would be students
with an IEP um we do need to probably
dig into what exactly is the denominator
but generally over the past few years
just looking at adequacy adequacy data
which is produced and published every
every year of course um uh the number
has been around 20% um actually I think
I've looked at it since the pandemic it
has been growing the percentage students
with an IEP um has been growing since
the pandemic by a few few percentage
points um and if you look at adequacy
spreadsheets you could see that as well
but this particular metric I think we
need to dig into how we're measuring the
denominator to get you um the fully
answer that question that kind of
reflects correctly with 17% in 2017 with
32,000 kids and then you're coming over
here with 36,000 kids with
21 yeah that's a trend we've seen in the
data the data has been showing that
consistently
okay
per well that that um that number also
has um you know has interesting
comparison with what's in the um FY 26
estimated number where you've got um
estimated
31,49 yeah for the fiscal year 26
adequacy estimate we just got copy and
paste the previous year's number got so
we don't do any estimate for
that can you go up to the top row there
um on the last sheet in that last column
we're looking at where you have 571
th000
student that's a heck of an increase
since 4,000 4
41,000 more than 20% back in
17 yes thank you that those would be the
Max cost um for the students eligible
for special education Aid so that's that
total cost that is submitted to the
department uh for reimbursements that
would be the total cost for the student
that's eligible in special education
a can I explain that a little bit more
for me please sure uh so all the
students that are so for fy4 that
$571,500 figure that's a student that
was submitted for special education Aid
that is a total cost that that District
submitted to U the special education
Bureau for reimburse for sped a so that
that is total cost for a student that's
eligible for for special education a is
that minus the
$70,000 that is the total cost it's just
relating to one student exactly correct
yes the high that's the most expensive
student correct in that year in that
yes sorry if that was confusing that
that was the attent thank you that's the
state cost right total or both total
okay yes that would be the total cost of
invoices submitted that you guys
approved just clarify eligible allowable
cost yes which means theoretically they
may have had some other invoices that
you guys did not Dem in you know to
match the IEP and so they could have
spent more but that's just what the
department found appropriate for that
IEP do you review all these invoices in
detail to to decide whether that's a
permissible cost or not expense Melissa
white division director for learner
support so all of the invoices are
submitted individually we look at every
single invoice that is submitted for
special education Aid we go and we look
at the students IEP and then we match up
to see if the costs that are being
submitted on the invoice match what is
in the students IEP if what is submitted
is not in the IEP then we do not
reimburse them for that cost so these
are just for the costs they could
provide to us a number of invoices but
we will look at only the things that are
in the IEP and that are are eligible and
then we reimburse based on that so this
is an entire reimbursement basis the
district has already incurred the cost
and paid for them they submit them to us
for last year we go through we spend
several months going through all of the
invoices and then determine okay these
are the total Statewide expenses that
are eligible under special education Aid
and then we look at our amount that is
allocated which is that 33.9 million and
then we prate it based on that so I want
to clarify not all leas submit for
special education Aid so you're seeing
there was a lot of questions about why
not here why not there not all of them
submit these are just the ones that we
receive submissions for and that have
eligible costs so we might receive some
and then they're not eligible we would
have turned around turned around and
just um deny the request for special
education we've heard that before but
why are they not submitting that's a
question that you is for the leas that's
not something that I can
answer isn't it possible they just don't
have high this is just high cost
students right we're talking that meet
the requirements that's laid out in the
RSA so it's certain possible that a
number of laas just don't have may La
local Education Agency do they all have
a
director um if they're operating a
special education program then yes they
and when you've got the the Max total
cost per student is that the Max
reimbursable cost or that's actually all
um approved
costs including the costs that the
for thank you yes that would be the
total cost that the district submitted
for reimbursement to the special
education Bureau so all costs from 0 to
3.5 3.5 to 10 and then total cost for
student yeah take one student yep thank
you sorry I didn't understand question
yes represent coom thank you Mr chairman
uh do you guys also keep track of the
costs that you um deny uh that are
submitted but you denied you keep track
of that number as well I don't keep
track of that number
no represent
papovich thank you Mr chair so um if I
recall correctly and I just want to make
sure I remember it when we had the
hearings for this you guys testify that
you can review the invoices for matching
the type of service for the IEP correct
but you do not have any way to determine
whether the cost is reasonable or
appropriate or what not so if a district
charge is 100 for a service and another
charges a thousand both of them get
approved as long as the service matches
the IEP requirements correct we do not
rate set at the department for those
types of services and I think another
question that had come up earlier with
regards to you know cost of special
education teachers and that type of
thing and looking at case loads each
district pays their teachers differently
so you're going to have a special
education teacher in one District that
makes a certain amount and a special
education teacher in another District
that makes a different amount and they
all you know have a a pay schedule based
on their years of experience as well so
I mean it's it's not really comparing
Apples to Apples because it's going to
be varied depending on that school and
their collective bargaining agreement
that type of thing so if you look at the
old form we used to have for breaking
down what the how we arrive at the base
cost for Education you probably haven't
seen it but Mark has and and so if I
take the what we appropriate in
differentiate Aid at
$2,184 are projecting for the next year
and multiply that by
30 uh 30 kids per case load it comes off
um is that basically without benefits
the cost of a special education teacher
around 65
district okay it's going to depend on
the on the district it's going to depend
upon the district is that in the as an
average is that close so if you multiply
it by 1.33
33% it's going to be much higher than
that total cost little shallow of
$100,000 I think it's just going to
depend on the
district I guess I don't understand the
question because if I'm looking at
trying to figure out how much I make in
we versus how much I make in hopkington
there's going to be a considerable
difference between the two long we have
to build a budget here and and and uh
unless we do it how much each district
should get but we don't do it like that
we try to find an average cost of a
teacher and go from there U or a
principal or a guidance counselor or
what have
you I'm I'm arguing I'm sorry um or
trying to
explain
yes so it just says as of February 2025
the average salary for a teacher in New
$4,399 is 326 I I've got that and I've
seen that and we've calculated that up
my concern is though if you're talking
about special education teacher that's
teaching speech they're going to have to
have a master's degree right but the
highest is also
61754 and that would probably
be with longevity right I don't
know yeah and see what I was calculating
right here by just multiplying that
number by 30 thinking it's 30 is a case
load it comes out to 60 6 65.5 th000
yeah I don't know yeah yeah okay further
questions yes McGuire thank thank you Mr
chairman so the two um communities I
like to compare are Manchester and marac
partially because they're on the same
page and they're very
large um so the the different both of
them have uh roughly 20 something perent
of their kids are in special ed and
Statewide we spending uh close to
$30,000 a kid in Special Ed but marac
spends
$36,000 per kid in special ed and
Manchester spends under
$24,000 right so marac spends 50% more
on their typical IEP than Manchester
does so is there so so clearly they're
they're kind of do doing too much in my
opinion right just from that number um
by comparison is there anything way we
can help marac act more like
Manchester these are all different kids
with different needs and these are
different programs that have come up
with determinations on how they're going
to meet the children's needs so I I
think there's a lot of questions about
the granularity of services and the cost
of those services and that's just not
something that we can do okay at the
department may I follow up M so but the
problem is in Manchester we're talking
about 2900 kids and in marac I'm talking
about 800 kids right so the average is
going to be pretty
good do you see what I mean I mean it's
not like two or three kids and yes this
could be a really high-end kit these are
these are going to be the averages is is
typical is is more accurate I guess
involved I'm not sure what the question
is so so when I saying is do we have
any do you do any instruction any
guidance any um auditing any control to
to look at this number and say
much again we we don't rate set so we
wouldn't say anything about the cost of
how a district is choosing to spend
their on their special education
services we do in we go in and do
monitoring and make sure they're meeting
their requirements set aside in federal
law and in state law but no we don't go
in and tell them how they should spend
those funds that's a local level
determination I think that's a question
Ed yes yeah AR aren't those aren't isn't
the IEP I mean you you I think you
testified earlier that that you qualify
the costs based on what's in the I we
don't yes we just determine if the costs
are allowable so if the service was put
in for speech services let's say and
they're asking for reimbursement for
speech services but speech services are
not in the IEP we will not reimburse so
you're looking at the IEP correct and
the IEP was prepared by the IEP team at
the local level so it's not just the Lea
it's actually it involves a team of
people right so so you're you're correct
in saying that the decision is made at
the local level but it's actually made
at the local level by an i team not the
school board or the building principle
correct but when you say you're looking
at the IEP you're just looking to see if
there's a speech IEP you're not looking
down in the the grains of that IEP are
you like like for example the state of
Arkansas audits one in 10 IEPs to ensure
what they're billing out is
appropriate when we talked to them on
the horn here what two weeks ago or
three weeks ago we talked to the
director special ed down there and that
program down there when they're looking
at these
costs they ensure that they audit one in
every 10 IEPs in that state I know
that's pretty high bar for you guys to
do here with the staff you have but yes
State funds 0.25 FTE for special
education staff at the department so
when you say you look at the IPS you
look to see if there is an IP like
emotionally handicapped or or
or uh physically handicap I hire two
seasonal part-time staff members that
come on just to review those special
education Aid invoices and they look at
is it in the IEP they're not doing an
analysis of whether it's appropriate for
the student or if the services are
appropriate they're not looking at that
piece of it they're just looking at is
it in the IEP and then can we reimburse
for that that's do you look actually at
the IEP we look at the IEP how do you
system
okay and no there's a hand over
yes thank you um I just wanted to follow
up on representative Maguire's question
and you had mentioned earlier every
student is different and every and their
needs are all different and so if it's
marac Manchester kind of
situation I would think that that
student
whose um the cost associated with
educating that student was
$571,000 could have been in the Marram
district is that accurate to say so it
could just change the numbers pretty
drastically correct okay thank
you
yes thank you Mr chair you want earlier
that you don't trate set we are by by
now we all get it if hypothetically we
would like to start going down that road
where we would ask the Department of
Education to start putting together say
county level appropriate you know levels
of reimbursement for certain
Services can you tell me a bit about
what type of staff and resources
timeline complexity of the project is
that something that we could you know if
we suggested that you go down that path
what would it take in both time and
resources I think I would need time to
do an analysis to see what that would
entail before just answering it off the
cuff
here I'd appreciate if you would because
I can guarantee more questions will be
asked on that
later McGuire yeah so we have more deta
more detail in front of us here and it's
not what you just described it's all in
the the 0 to 70k range that's the where
the big differences between Manchester
and marac the higher end range they're
not out of line with each other in
anyway it's it's the basic um lower
level
you so what would happen if we reduce
that from zero from 70 down lower so
that the state starts cutting in a
little earlier in the game
here just going back to what you
mentioned this is what they submitted
for reimbursement so it might very well
be that the special education Aid that
they submitted for I mean it may not
fall into there we can just go by what
we've received that's the only data we
really
have I think what we have here is more
complete I'm sorry
representative um lad could you oh my
question was we have some bills which
are going the way we've done before from
three and a half times down to two and a
half times
or
lower
um that's where the majority of our
special education IEPs are and so it
would take some of the burden off the
local and put more on state have you
looked into that as far as what would
happen if we did change and move that
back off maybe you know instead of two
and a half times to or three and a half
to two and a half times per pupil cost
yes um there have been several bills
introduced the past several years that
have done that and we provided fiscal
notes that show what that would look
like so I can dig up the old fiscal
notes and provide that if needed thank
you
yes thank you um may I ask how would you
determine the amounts in those fiscal
notes because in asking questions you
know in previous hearings um we
understand that all the data you have
are for the you know catastrophic
students where the school district sees
that they are reaching the threshold to
start collecting so they will give you
all the invoices for that
student do you have any data for the
students that are under that threshold I
have to go back and look through because
we have done um estimates in the past on
um that I think it there was a maybe two
years ago there was a 2 and a half% and
there was a one and a half% so we
projected it at several different so
basically when you present those
estimates I would really appreciate if
it include some information on the
methodology and assumptions used to come
up with them so we understand because
you know a model can have any number of
assumptions that are required but in
order to understand the model we have to
understand what the you know ballpark
numbers you have to put in that word
thank you can do that Mr chair yes if I
could just tag on to that that that's a
point I remember we we definitely talked
about a couple years ago because uh
because the pool at 2.5 is clearly going
to be a lot larger yes than the pool at
3.5 and then it will increasingly
tighten as you as you go up so so being
able to be a look at um at a student
that maybe stopped at
2.6 you know and and and and um and that
may be you know something that we're not
getting from the uh the districts
because they weren't even close to um to
coming to the the 3.5
threshold and and I think we had we had
talked about this um Mr chair couple of
years ago well we talked a couple years
ago and we talked about it this year
where we're looking at these other
states where the locals have to pay the
first 15 grand no no I'm talking about
how we do the how we do the data
analysis oh how we do we can we can we
can do I think reasonable
projections um you know to what what
lower threshold points you know what
what three looks like what 2.5 looks
like what two looks like uh without just
working from the the the base of
invoices you know we've got now so so
thanks looking at previous year fiscal
notes and it looks like we did not make
an attempt to come up with an yeah you
said you couldn't do it yeah that's why
we never got it we were just told it's
not available
information uh so it's amazing reps and
Damon thank you excuse
me so you told us that there's not
setting from doe to districts for how
they Implement their special services
correct is their rate setting related to
out of District placements that the
state is paying
for um I believe that I would want to go
back and take a look at that and
actually ask Becky for debt but I'm
pretty sure there's a specific rate
setting for instate placements but not
for out of District instate placements
when we're looking at facility approv
approval but not out of
state so but I want to go back and look
just to see specifically because I'm
pretty sure they submit um the facility
will
submit a lot of their financial data and
then we're able to look at rate setting
based on that and then do an analysis
across several but it's the out of state
um placements that tend to not have that
in place and then that's where um we see
some of the
costs um are are much different compared
to inate
placements thank
you represent papovich if I may just
quickly again repeat a similar request
when you provide that data on the rate
setting process if you could be prepared
to explain you know in a bit of detail
how the process works right you know
it's nice to know it's generally about
the financials but what do you look at
you know how do you determine their
costs are reasonable and so on and so
forth cuz there there's always a
question between what's an appropriate
rate and what's an actual rate and it
can get really complicated and all of
this is on our website so all of the the
rate setting is placed on the website
for anyone to look
at have you had any recent discussions
with HHS regarding the cost that
Medicaid is taking on these out of state
placements uh and where that starts and
stops in terms of where our costs as the
stop so the out of District placements
that are court ordered placements or
episodes of treatments are done by
DHHS if they're not done by DHHS then
that would be the district making the
determination on where the student gets
placed if they're not done by DHHS what
are some of those Services which
are does it have to relate to the IEP
episodes of treatment and the um court
ordered placements and so the district
will cover the costs of the educational
portion of that as in the
IEP but if let's say an episode of
treatment student is placed and it's not
in the students's I AP then those costs
would
not and the
Transportation uh associated with that
out of state is paid by whom if it's in
the IEP it would would be paid by the
district and then they could that could
be a cost that they could reimburse for
special education Aid it would be an
eligible
cost the quarter to placements in the uh
episodes of treatment transportation is
I think included in the cost are there
any other questions here on the special
education component here yes represent
magu thank you is your system have
enough granularity such that
um the I says rather than just need
speech therapy it says needs two hours
of speech therapy per week or 10 hours a
week or something like that and does
your system know that that for a
particular Community the average speech
therapist hour is $100 or $200 or
something like that no no can't you
can't sort of tease that out that that's
not available no okay if a district
hires a speech therapist there's the
cost for that speech therapist that is
set by The District's collective
bargaining agreement if they're not able
to get one they might have to contract
that work out so then the cost is going
to be different so it because it varies
across the state across who they're able
to actually um procure to give the
services to the students it just there's
so much variance but given collect that
data
and the other part too is yes if a
student is receiving special education
um speech services and maybe there twice
a week at you know 30 minutes it's in a
narrative format there's not some way
for us to capture that and then do some
sort of analysis it's just written in
The Narrative of the students IEP so
that's why it's a lot of work for the
person to go and actually look at the
bill or the invoice and then look at the
IEP because they're reading it in a
narrative
format how is the billable hour
established
for a student which is re receiving some
Medicaid support that that's been
referred by the school nurse or by a
person that's qualified to do that with
Medicaid even some of our age three
through five bracket and I'm just trying
to find out yes there's such a thing as
ailable hour for
Audiology that we could find in in start
using as a measure of cost for an hour's
worth of work I would think DHHS might
be able to provide that information we
wouldn't have that because at the
Department of Education we don't deal
with Medicaid at all so any of the
Medicaid that the um district is trying
to seek reimbursement for they go
through a separate system and they um
handle that internally themselves we
don't have any involvement with that
piece of it further questions so special
education yes G and
luno thank you very much Mr chair so I
was wondering I want to go back to the
um that the row with the Max total cost
per student and I I get it this is for
the the of of all the students that were
involved in the reimbursement request
this is the one that had the highest um
um cost associated with them and I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about what sort of services go into
driving a cost of to 57 almost
$572,000 uh for a for a single student
and maybe talk a little bit about how
that cost I mean it you know did it you
know was it most of the students and
then and then one or was there sort of
like this taper that that went like the
the the second the second to the maximum
cost was
$570,000 I'm just wonder if you could
talk a little bit about the services
that go into that and you know know how
many students across the state are are
in that ballpark I do appreciate the
question I can't speak to the specifics
of it because I didn't look at the IEP
myself so I can't say what the services
or what the student is receiving I I
can't speak to that at all and the cost
associated with that I apologize but I
can't because I don't
know
okay yes represent Brown thank you
last work session uh we were told that
the submitted invoices may not detail or
differentiate travel time versus a
service time for a specialist that comes
in is there any way the invoices for the
IEPs and or or the IEPs themselves can
be more specific in terms of the
breakdown of um the time involved for
these
services so I think the time involved
getting back to the previous example
that we just talked about speech therapy
twice a week 30 minutes like that
information will be listed in The
Narrative of the IEP but as far as the
travel time the travel time may not be
in the I AP necessarily but it would be
on the invoice re receed so if we were
reimbursing for mileage we would have to
see from that Transportation Company
dates of services where the student was
provided transportations that would have
to be on there um some of them if it's
urement for mileage that would have to
be on there but if they have a set rate
per trip and then it would show like
location if it's from the school to um
maybe where services are being provided
or something like that that is detailed
receive
yes but that wouldn't be entered into
necessarily like we would look at that
and we would say that that was an
allowable cost but we're not recording
that somewhere we wouldn't re-recording
mileage or Transportation or breaking it
down and um on the single sheet where it
says Statewide count out of District
this is historical cost Trends by age
group um lower right corner it says we
had
1464 students out of District how many
of those were out of state do we know
and how and by state could we find out
whether it was massachus sit
main what states those
were thank you uh I don't have that
prepared unfortunately at this moment we
can uh gather that so the 1464 figure we
could look at to determine how many of
those are within out of District but
within State and then how many are out
of state and by state we can we can look
into
that are there any other questions for
the
Department I think we're done with the
so obviously we're not taking any action
any of this today but we need to be
starting to filter this down I guess
looking at the formulas for gluing This
Together uh what's our funding formula
going to look like um uh how are we
going to address special education Aid I
I think these are really two big
elephants in the room here that we need
to now get down to yeah can I can I ask
a question what what are our takeaways
from from the last hour and a half of
looking at this what what are the things
that are really jumping off this that we
I represents billsburg yeah I mean I'll
volunteer a few observations and I think
they're just confirming what most of us
already this really know if we don't
specifically quantifiably know it but uh
Statewide student enrollment since 17
has declined from
184,000 to about
169,000 simultaneously the student count
323646 717 so we've got declining
student enrollment but an increasing
percentage of the students with IEPs
that's gone up from
175% to 21 a. half% a 4% increase in
seven years is frightening
tramatic um I think that uh the total
cost a billion dollars more or less on
special ed is just astonishing and then
when you see that the districts are by
and large covering 85% of it you can
understand why it's a constant human
crime from the districts and affects
their budget so radically and then I'm
looking uh at our third uh page chart
here picking up Fall Mountain which uh
you know I know intimately enough to put
these figures in
perspective um their
uh their CAD Aid claims I guess is the
right way to put that about
uh uh one point 2
million they would have been eligible
for about half of that in reimbursement
612,000 but because of the pration which
is so sharp nearly a third um this cuts
down the the actual uh reimbursement to
421,000 so instead of getting half back
they're getting a third back so it's
just you know I don't know how we as a
state get under
control um alleviating the burden on our
schools and I just wonder what is
driving the uh increased number of
students on IEPs The increased
percentage The increased costs what
what's what are the root problems
that I I think that's a rhetorical
question I don't think there's an answer
for us today yeah and and so so thank
thanks for that representative spilsbury
because you know a lot of that a lot of
that what you talked about those are
numbers that we can see from the
adequacy spreadsheets you can see the
enrollment Trends you can see the number
of of um of students across the state
and by District you know um uh receiving
special that are on IEPs because it's
right in the different Sheed a um so um
part it very much presents an outof
control fixture doesn't it well but but
but on here there's there's there there
were some obviously some numbers where
there's a where there's a just a a rapid
growth over over a short six-year period
like from um 388,000 is the Max total
cost student in 2019 to to now 200,000
almost 200,000 more um 5
171,000 uh for that and um not sure how
many students are are are in that in
that sort of you
know significant need category because I
was I
mean 21 over attributed to average
student customer I don't know if that
those are these are all dollar amounts
not student counts so um so we're not
we're not we're not necessarily seeing
student count Trend data in in this in
this you know in the in the special
education Aid which is the most
severe we're seeing cost Trend data
submitted yeah but but but but by by
sort of you know by these sort of
categories you know between you know
below three and a half between three and
a half and 10 and above 10 and where
where's the growth um coming from and um
because it certainly seems like that
that Top Line has has grown
significantly
um it does appear to me that the
increased student count is a significant
driver but that the costs per student
significant but we also received I
couldn't put my hands on it just then um
information we had a chart showing the
13 IEP categories and there were certain
categories which were exploding on
us and that would you know I think
that's a reflection on our society it's
a reflection maybe on how we're
addressing some of the stuff in the
schools um
um expectations aspirations all that
stuff come into play here um and uh so I
think that we need to be looking at that
and saying okay what's the root cost of
that uh we can see it as a result of
dollars but we can also see it result of
certain
IEPs
so what I'm taking away from this is
that we're putting a heavy burden on the
local school district to provide a
program which costing one out of every
education and and in some districts more
like one out of three yeah yeah yeah
so so I think whatever we do we have to
take remember that and try and
incorporate into what we're trying to
achieve in terms of funding and
education
here but we also have to send a message
out that you know
that it can't it we got somehow
get in charge oversight of this program
somehow uh to I'm not saying we're were
misidentifying some of these kids but
the costs are just you know we can't
keep going like that so what's what's
the answer is it how we're teaching uh
the instruction the curriculum how we're
grouping how we're structuring how we're
organizing um how our families are the
parenting yeah so so so Mr chair I mean
if if Ian you know we're talking about
just looking at the last the last column
on the very last page 169,000
um kids and there's um 870 Statewide
that were subject to reimbursement in
the in the special education grant and
and and and interest I'm interested in
the I'm not interested in where the kids
are who the kids are or anything like
that but the distribution of of that 870
into the into the different buckets the
below three well there's zero below 3.5
because we don't you know do that but
3.5 to 10 and above and above 10 and um
and then and then maybe even getting
some gradient in terms of in terms of um
case I don't know what the term is um
but but it it it takes something to get
up to almost
$600,000 I mean I uh you know the
department did not have an answer to
what went into a
$600,000 uh those those those children
are the minority first work cost our big
costs are what we talked about below
it's down lower and and uh it's I I I
feel it's identification I looked at for
example the city of
Hanover how much how many kids are in in
in receiving special Aid support there
zero you're telling me there's no child
there that's getting some support they
have differentiated aid but there's
nothing there in cat
a so I think a lot has to do with how
local is running the show and I
understand Hanover has a different
population I understand achievement
scores are probably off the charts uh
but you know it I've always thought that
kids regardless of wealth had
handicapping
conditions very no no AB absolutely
absolutely
um yeah I I guess I'm just wondering if
if if this if if if this this
information is really what we need um to
work from or if it's something else that
gives us a picture of what you're trying
to what we're all trying to get a better
understanding of so that we can um we
can address concerns that you've
presented in terms of the definition of
IEPs and and then what um what sort of
what sort of services um you know are
you know provided by the in the
different way 13 different I no no no
categories uh that that I'm not sure
this this is really putting
the putting the the help to get to a
solution standpoint that's that's it's
further identifying that there's an
issue that there's an issue I GRE doing
that represent poit you had your hand up
and then represent cop thank you I um
just wanted to let the committee know
that I took the liberty of speaking with
Melisa and asking her for um breakdown
of these students that get catastrophic
Aid 800 800 900 of them in total cost
and broken down in buckets of 10K like
70 to 80 80 to 90 Statewide so there is
no privacy issue you know I don't want
to see that by District because then you
really narrow it down so you know when
she sends it to the to Jennifer
everybody will get it but I wanted you
to know that uh you know that was
requested I took the liberty of and I
did want to check if we know if we'll
exact that bill today or not paron me
are we going to exact that bill that we
were on had on the back burner because
of the amendment one bill so we we could
wipe off really quickly here the one
that you did the amendment on represent
Damon so are we yeah well represent coom
had her hand up here thank you Mr
chairman I don't know if the Department
of Education members who are here can
answer this question or not but you you
brought up the 13 14 categories that we
received from Becky fet and what I'm
noticing on this is that for
2023 the number of um Statewide
disability here is 32,019 but they're
showing on this report that it's
35717 so I'm curious where the 3, 3500
um difference is in that that number of
students that are um counted with IEPs
and the other thing I was wondering is
if we could maybe get um the def of
emotional um disturbance and how that is
utilized in this report you know who are
they classifying into the emotional
disturbance but the numbers on this
report are not balancing with the
numbers on this report for those years
they're they're quite different yeah
Mark Mark can answer that because we've
had that question before so so there's
different ways to measure student yeah
ad admr
BKK um we have to dig into exactly what
the differences are but um I been asked
to do that as far as denominator number
um but it's probably just a measur of
how student is
defined or is it the time in which that
number derived
from can we also have do you happen to
know what's going into the emotional
disturbance how
that's defined so that we know what
class okay
thanks okay let Pard me oh represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman
so to me um the numbers of of who gets
an i
IEP seem relatively accurate right if
you look at for every single School
District the percentage of their kids
who have an IEP is either High Teens or
low
20% right it's 19% 20% 21% like that um
and and those things are we somebody has
an i AP or not is apparently determined
ex completely locally so if you have 200
school districts everyone is getting
roughly the same sort of number then
it's accurate okay what's
different is how much is being spent on
the average IEP right so I gave you the
exam the examp my favorite examples of
Manchester and marac but but there are
some districts that are that the amount
they spend per IEP is quite low and
others it's quite high so it seems to me
that's where the local there's local
variance and it's also where the
incentives we give them are backwards
because the way we give
um whatever is formerly known as
catastrophic Aid I guess it's special
special ed Aid sped Aid okay
um the more you spend the more we give
right and and we start at a very high
end so you know but but
also so I I guess I would be like the
incentive to be what we want which is
make your
averages near the state average right in
terms of spending so so the point being
if your average spending per I AP is at
or below the state average will give you
you know x% of that cost but if your
average starts to creep up over the
state average right and maybe we could
do this just for the the
basic sped costs the 0 to 70k types then
we would give you a lesser percent of
that number if you see what I mean right
so so we could we could try to to push
the incentive to keeping your costs
under control because right now all
we're saying is you know you have a
speech therapist yes okay I'll pay the
check right but but is it a $500 speech
therapist is it a $200 speech therapist
we don't care right so so
um that seems to me to make some sense
is is align the incentives with keeping
costs under control thank you Mr chair
okay we
yes um so thank you very much for
listening I I have to disagree you said
The more you spend the more we give um
but we're only giving um I think it was
representative spillsbury said around a
around a third of the cost so the
incentive is nowhere near to make to say
oh gee I should spend a whole lot more
money because I'm going to get a whole
lot more because I'm still going to have
to come up with 2third of what I am
spending so I I I disagree I don't
believe that the incentive is there to
spend more money on uh special ed
students okay um yes represent fellows
um yes I just I I understand U
representative Maguire's you know want
to get a handle on this but to expect
all the districts to have something
that's close to the same average just
doesn't make any sense because you have
Manchester that has thousands of
students and then and then you have a
district that's only the elementary
level and only has 200 students and you
put a family moves into the district and
they have you know three kids that need
special ed you just can't expect them
everybody to get on the same page in
terms of a
percentage that absolutely makes sense
right so so it's only the the larger
districts that could
be controlled in in the what I'm the way
I'm
describing okay what what I'd like to do
before we head head out today is to take
care
484 that's a bill relative re
reallocation repurposing Career
space we had agreed upon an amendment
right here is that um something to in
order to move this CTE Bill
forward there you go so um I'd like to
hand the gav to the vice
3 we're we're reallying this yes
484 and why is it going to me you making
well because I want to make a motion to
get out of here
okay all right so I'm going to reopen
the executive session on 8 B
484 and recognize representative lad for
an amendment yes I'd like to make a
Mo okay so we have a second would you
like to speak to the motion yes I'd like
to make a motion to approve
0358 H this is an amendment to
484 and it makes the change there you
can see on lines 7 through
nine can do we have a second for the
amendment second uh representative
peoples okay describe your Amendment
please uh I I'll pass okay any further
disc discussion on the amendment this of
morning seeing none um show show of
just did anybody read
compare it to the original Amendment
it's just a highlighted yes yes okay so
that's a
yes okay so the amendment make a motion
and D in a second the amendment is uh
approved uh
180 and uh so we are now back to uh uh
would you like to make a motion yes I'd
like to make a motion otpa on HP 484
with Amendment 035
8h and seconded by representative
Damon I have no
discussion yes representative C thank
you just noticing that the effective
so no this amendment only replaces SE so
the that date remains there yeah yep the
underlying Bill contains the effective
date glad to clarify any further
comments okay then we can move to the
roll call on
representative Maguire yes
representative ER yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
Mi
mahagan
yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows no
representative Damon yes representative
Ricky no representative kitan yes
representative Weinstein
yes so we have 16 yay and two
no the vote the vote being 16 Ys and two
NOS um could go on consent if there's
nobody objecting right there's no money
in this I think we're going to do a
Minority Report okay and represent
bricky or representative bricky will
write The Minority Report and
representative
lad majority yes we write the majority
report okay so that's going on the
regular calendar thank you and with that
we've come to a close of the meeting
today so we're going to adjourn and uh I
will be putting together an agenda for
the next week this evening and you'll
know about it tomorrow
so pardon